you
well
after a long hiatus
we are
back
it's quiet
[Applause]
a little quiet i was hearing like really
quiet wendy's bringing death in my ear
yeah like am i here
guys we are back
fupa troopers rejoice
family family family
family family family family family stop
i've been missing the sound bite
[Music]
yeah it's been a long break
you know i missed you guys
i my fear my fear when i take these long
breaks is always that nobody comes back
everyone stops caring they go
they're like i've seen enough of that
show i'm over it yeah
you know they're like i wa i'm watching
uh
jordan peterson uh
savage
savage moments savage moment compilation
yeah jordan has must have a podcast oh
i'm into joe rogan now
toxic masculinity what a horrible phrase
yeah actually did you know that somebody
or well there's a book about jordan
peterson called
savage messiah
with a forward from dennis prager and
someone took a photo of it on the
subreddit it was at the dollar store
very savage
a savage messiah savage about a four
days savage moments yeah whoa it's real
how dr jordan peterson is saving western
throw it up throw it up i know we're
already getting into it real quick
anyway not even like how you're doing
yeah crew
oh yeah savage messiah with a forward
from dennis prager who's like the top
propagandist of the right
add to cart and the dollar store
important message no if you check the
subreddit you'll see that somebody
spotted them literally at the dollar
store
don't get ripped off with this uh 19.99
no no no don't be paying full price okay
got it
anyway my point is is that i'm always
afraid you guys are going to leave me
yeah
right
so to those of you who stayed thank you
today's uh episode is sponsored by babel
curology hellofresh and stamps.com who
we love so well here's this jordan
peterson savage messiah for one dollar
if anybody do we have the location if
anybody wants to get a good discount
savage messiah how dr jordan peterson is
saving western civilization
wow
what am i going to do
trust me
yo i'm sorry but like if you someone
writes a book about you called savage
messiah you better you need to speak out
against that
that title immediately puts you in the
dollar store right
and anyway anyway whatever enough about
him for now
um we're back i hope you guys all had a
good break you know i saw lots of love
while we were gone people missing the
show which was really nice we missed you
know i was missing the show so much
during my break i'll say we were gone
for about three weeks although we got we
had to leave it was more like four yeah
what happened though last week we got
banned
a strike on a two-year-old video yeah
that was
yeah that ended up getting reversed yeah
right yeah and then covered it's been a
lot of time i forget that stuff so much
happened so wait you forgot something
else too which i want to talk to you
about i did well you're transitioning
into this topic right now so we'll
just
go it's been a long time i have to tell
you it's a lot of stuff has passed
um it's been a long time
so what was the old video it was like
it was like a thanksgiving episode
okay so it was our last year's thanks
yeah that's crazy we never even got to
talk about it yeah right yeah we never
even got to [ __ ] about getting banned
yeah yeah so we had a whole incredible
christmas fantastic episode that we were
hyping for months yeah which by the way
is happening this friday yeah so the
holiday season is over but don't fret
we're gonna get the christmas special
a month late but we are gonna do it
so um
yes so we were getting ready it was the
night before
and i go oh yo you got a strike on this
two like a year old video the
thanksgiving special we did you laugh
you lose right and apparently one of the
videos i showed
was a russian dude jumping out of a
window
yeah and
i i don't know i think they have like a
a a stack of
oh did we post a social
yeah we did
we went up on social media we didn't
take our family family oh the family
photo on friday but oh yeah right that's
true
right
anyway this guy jumped out of window and
apparently this was on some kind of a
black list of like naughty videos to get
you
immediately banned and i looked up the
video by the way and the guy lived he
didn't even die
yeah he was fine and i was like straight
up didn't even die
if he died maybe i would get it but he
did it
well in the video he jumps out of a
window and and catch and he goes on to a
tree and like catches himself not like
he's dangerous but no he he didn't catch
that tree dan i think that was the
problem that dude like a bag of [ __ ]
sand dude
no he hit the ground but
i guess you know they have rules against
dangerous promoting dangerous activity
yeah
but anyway so we got an old strike
and i think it was on the coattails of
some controversy too i think some we
were getting mass flagged by trish's
stands or something or some other stanz
joe rogan well the joe rogan beef hadn't
happened yet
you know
um
yeah
so we got banned had couldn't do the
show
is so it was like a four month
uh four week
felt like forever
four weeks off the show
first two weeks was like
you know usually what i do on the
weekend is i play i'll just chill
watch some tv play video games i did
that for a week and then i was like i
can't do this i can't do this
somebody saved me from
wake me up can't wake me up inside
that was what i was that was my
soundtrack after the first week
also as the break was happening uh on
omicron
was going wild and crazy
chronic yeah omicron
finch
we couldn't have our nanny and we had a
whole week with
no nanny theodore
oh yeah all right and then we had like
full on theodore time that was intense
bro i'm telling you it's intense having
a the energy that you enjoy
he just he this kid he's literally a
wind-up toy he'll just start stomping
around in circles sometimes he gets so
jacked on energy he'll just start
stomping in circles
and it's like theodore yeah
it's like he can't contain himself he
gets so freaking energetic and he he
makes us laugh all the time and but he
loves whenever he makes us laugh then
he'll do it again and again and again
he's like definitely a little comedian
yeah he loves he loves
so he so one time i was on the phone
and i said what the [ __ ] about something
and then theodore started going what the
[ __ ]
oh i actually have a video can you send
it to them wait but it's just audio
because we're not oh yeah maybe just
play the audio we made the decision to
stop showing theodore's face like a year
ago since he got getting older and we
don't want people to recognize him yeah
we want to give him
give him the decision to make at what
age do you think he can decide
16 or 18.
um i would say at least 16. at least 16.
yeah
um
it's hard by the way it's hard not to
share because it's so cute and funny
yeah and it's like so much about our
life at home
oh yeah just played into the mic oh you
think that's good oh you could say
yeah we'll get through so i'm sitting
there and i go what the [ __ ] and then he
goes what the [ __ ] and i started
cracking up dude
was so funny
and then um
like
i had to stop
i had to stop laughing because
yeah because i didn't want to promote
him to keep i don't want to encourage
him right i mean the kid has preschool
and i mean come on
no no no no
okay just say that
[Laughter]
the video's so cute i'm sad you guys
can't see it
okay
he keeps looking in the camera and
saying it
that's a naughty word you can't see it
so anyway
so anyway we i force myself to stop
laughing i go i
and he's just going right in my face
what the [ __ ] i'm like
so week passes and then me and ela like
he definitely forgot all about it yeah
no mention of it
so a week later we're all hanging out in
the living room
and then
he comes from the other side of the room
and he starts walking towards me
he go he's crawling around the couch he
goes behind your back he comes right
into my face like this he's never done
that before his face is like two inches
from mine and he's staring at me and i
go
theodore what's going on and he goes
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
and i started cracking up but
i i i don't laugh with that
not funny not funny yeah i think we have
our first uh theodore soundbite yeah
exactly
what the [ __ ]
you know how south park those really
cute kid voices we could do we could
have theodore dude kid voices chris be
like theodore say keemstar's a [ __ ] oh
my god
keith keemstar's a [ __ ] i don't know
about that
yeah i'm just kidding
maybe something though
you know
oh man so i have two weeks left by the
way
yeah which is part i want to stand up
and show or know i guess
yeah let's get it so big you never see
it properly on camera got that fresh uh
jersey shore trip
ela got that uh huge italian dad dressed
too by the way know it's green actually
but yeah i i didn't realize
not used to h3tv
um
yeah so i kind of been feeling like i
might as well come today because i don't
know how many shows i have
left yeah it could happen at any moment
at this point yeah because your due date
is the 31st right yeah so it can happen
at any moment
yep
what the [ __ ]
are you excited are you nervous to get
it out how are you feeling um
i feel both
i'm like
what the [ __ ]
the whole last month we've been
during the break been preparing the
house and the room and
washing all the clothes and all this
stuff i forgot about baby world yeah all
different baby world you need so much
stuff for a baby like to take care of a
baby also like extreme sanitizing you
have to boil every bottle yeah
after use
are you gonna are you gonna let them
know on your titty
you mind if i'm gonna breastfeed yeah
i don't know i don't really want to
so i think i'm just
gonna like
just in the beginning let it happen if
it happens but i really don't want to
like my experience last time was like
awful yeah traumatizing i don't know if
some of you guys are new i didn't but
like
um either had trouble lactating and the
nurses there there it's like a cult
there where they are
think that you absolutely need to
breastfeed and theodore was starving
basically literally starving it was one
of the worst weeks of my life the whole
first week was just him crying non-stop
and we didn't know what to do it's just
awful
yeah that's what i would say try for a
day
but this time i'm bringing like formula
with that yeah i'm not baby starving
no and also it's not for me i don't like
the whole lifestyle that comes with it
like that's true you have to be ready to
pop your boob at any minute and it's all
about you
providing titty yeah boob coming out
yeah zach where are you with that boob
coming out
with her boob coming out it's not for me
i don't like it and also when you can
give him formula we can split the
i can feed him exactly well that's not
true they have fake titties where you
could put your breast milk you just have
to pump it for me okay so i just have to
sit and pump all day
you know the truth is guys speed one
moment then pump then like you have no
life other than being like a pump
machine the truth is there is a lot of
uh
there is like a cult of breastfeeding
and a lot of misinformation of like i
feel like there's a lot of women they're
made to feel less than if they can't
breastfeed and that's that's [ __ ]
that's just not true at all and it was
so frustrating like i kept trying and
nothing was coming out and they're like
okay like a failure yeah and they're
like okay try pumping eight times a day
and it's like i also want to be able to
do something else during the day other
than like pump take care of a newborn
baby that's crying
um still heal from labor
you know like there's so much going on
and you need to worry about
producing milk you did pump all freaking
day and nothing i did nothing not like
you didn't try no i tried it was awful
i'm just like
i've had my experience and i'm not
interested in it again
yeah i think the first day there's some
kind of like clear fluid that comes out
that's like good for the baby
and i remember that did come out for the
year yeah so maybe just that and then
if it if you don't lactate again then
like don't even yeah it's better for
everyone just to give them the formula
and everybody's like oh you gotta eat
really well you gotta rest you gotta
drink more water it's like i'm doing all
of that shut up
you know
it just doesn't it just doesn't work
sometimes i mean back in the day they
had wet nurses that was that was ladies
who they were just
leaking milk all day because they had
they just had that gene mm-hmm you know
so that's it now we got this
is another kind of milk no we're not
feeding him that kind of milk
that's
zack
off
that is a forbidden milk [ __ ]
and it works for some people
so i'm not you know this is just my
experience
both ways are great yeah we have friends
who
i we have a friend that breastfed her
kid until like two years old so
they loved it
right
i have a yeah i mean my mom breast
failed me until i was eight and that was
really failed she breastfed me till i
was eight years old i'm totally normal
is it possible that you weren't able to
lactate because i drank it all before he
was born
[Laughter]
mommy
um
so but yeah i think there's there's a
lot
women should not be felt like they need
to do one choice or the other made to
feel inadequate in any way
or you know both choices are good and
fine and healthy
and theodore is a genius yeah god forbid
that kid had another like five iq points
well there's a conspiracy that like kids
who are breastfed have an additional
five iq points which i don't believe by
the way i don't believe that's crazy
anyway
we're back
how was your guys break it was good
went uh every almost everybody went
somewhere at one point to like visit
family and everything
i went to i went to idaho to visit uh
ali's family
uh ab you were back in michigan right
yes sir
that was interesting
yeah and everybody was sick so we
couldn't see anyone half of our friends
and family were sick so we missed out on
seeing a lot of family with the rogue
yeah
the roanoke got him and we got food
poisoning
that took up about a week in my vacation
so it was a good time
that sounds great you know what you ate
yeah i went to go meet my mom's
boyfriend and we went to some restaurant
some nice restaurant but i got sick uh
i don't know nice restaurant got you
yeah it was i was i got lamb chops but
somehow
it was death it was like brutal yeah and
then my brother got it oh wow yeah it's
a nightmare hey did you like your mom's
boyfriend
uh it was interesting i met my dad's
girlfriend too so this is a new dynamic
with the parents having yeah i didn't
know my mom was dating anyone yeah wow
she's dating a jewish guy too and he
when i met him she's like he's like so i
heard you work on la with a bunch of
jews and i'm like a bunch of jews you're
surrounded by it maybe god forbid
yeah it's good times good times yeah so
so is it possible your mom is dating a
jew to spite your dad
possibly possibly
when my father was uh
my father was young he lost his house in
the war
um
so maybe it's just to add on to the
spike
yeah yeah
and how do you like your dad's
girlfriend she's really nice yeah so you
like your who do you like better
they're both really nice my parents are
the mean ones they were actually both
nice i feel bad for them more than my
friends
fair enough
um
is uh zach how was your break oh it was
very relaxing chill uh
didn't do a lot just stayed in watched a
bunch of movies and uh
yeah i took it easy didn't go to uh
wyoming to go see jeffrey yeah you
failed bro
i off before break the last thing i said
to zach was if you come back with a
picture of jeffree star and a yak
together then i'm gonna buy you a rolex
what happened i uh
i got scared of the cron so uh didn't in
wyoming
yeah they're masculine country out there
that's the only thing
there's only like 20 people
yeah the population density i think i
think you'd be fine still those yak's
got the yakron though yeah
okay
yeah it was chill it was relaxing miss
working is your doggy potty trained yet
how's that going he is turning into such
a good board there you go
you turn the corner i've never seen a
picture yeah i can uh i'll send it um
his name's bambi he's keeping it private
so nobody will recognize it
so he can have the decision to make he
can decide that for himself in a few
years he's turning into such a sweet
little boy there you go see you around
the corner yeah yeah good for you
ian
hey hey
uh it was fine i was a chipper uh intro
for you
energetic what's up dude what's up
what's up hey hey do you my friend
hey now new me new year new me okay okay
i like that i'm about 60 awake now
previously it was a little lower okay i
had a it was an okay break i i was gonna
go to new york to visit my friend but
then kovid was he was like don't come
here yeah it's so bad he's like all the
places we'd go are all closed he's like
don't bother so it was pretty
mellow break i'll postpone that to a
more you know ideal time but uh sam and
i are moving so i went and found a new
apartment during break
was that because of the downtown l.a
situation was so dicey i mean yeah the
neighborhood was getting a little iffy
where we live so we found a new um it's
like a haunted house it's pretty spooky
in there oh sh that doesn't sound better
at all
yeah i had to do some tough negotiating
with this new place you got a good price
yeah it's decent it's definitely so wait
is this is the neighborhood safe despite
the ghosts
uh
it's safer yeah it's mainly just the
ghosts okay but this guy i tried moving
in and
i won't get into the whole story but
there was this oven that they were
trying to let me accept as being the
oven that i'd get with the place
this thing's literally from 1953.
it was like ancient and so rusted i
could barely open the door it was like
i found one that looks it's not the same
but it looks super similar yeah as long
as it's not from 1942
[Laughter]
yeah that's cool no but this but it was
like imagine this but rusty and like it
actually looks like it's 70 years old
and i did it work no it was like oh
there's there's your problem when and
the guy's like well we kind of have a
policy like it would heat up he goes if
it heats up we won't replace it you know
did it heat up
barely
not enough to cook and i told them like
this is a fire hazard this thing's going
to explode at any moment yeah that's
true i can't be using this oven and he's
like
i don't know what we can do and i went
back and forth i've got an idea buy a
new oven [ __ ] i said and i go
i i said to him i was like dude i'm
almost positive richard nixon used this
oven like you have to change it
and he's like okay i'll go talk to him
and then he came back he's like we're
buying you a brand new oven i said how
what happened he goes i went to them and
i said richard nixon used that oven and
they went okay and they bought a new one
that was the thing huh the written nixon
lane this is more the condition yeah
cowboy's still worse than this
wow that's pretty bad but overall the
place is nice just a little haunted okay
how many people died in there
i mean over that one span of time
at least a couple dozen
at least a couple i'm definitely gonna
have to bring linda in there from the
ghost hunting video
i was going to say bye that would be a
great bit
you should do that for a sketch
will you do that i don't think sam would
want to know that information
can we have linda do a ghost analysis
she doesn't want it
well i mean well because it's it's
definitely more than one
she'll pick up well if any if you need
the protection spell there's a new
there's a person who just became a witch
i can ask for her
[Music]
do you know what i'm talking about
either
no
it's me that's what i was doing
yeah i studied
it's actually i'm a warlock not a witch
but
close enough okay and then also love how
was your break
love love lovebot's been actually
coaching yeah i love what's been acting
up what the hell he's like what's that
music is that the swedish national
anthem
what's happening what's happening right
now
it's just live
whoa
whoa why is he so high oh my god jumping
with swords
he's here
he's got his sword
the viking roots are strong
all the way from sweden
it's love himself
slade what's up everyone
what's up what's up what's up what's up
wow what an entrance wow here yeah go
ahead i'm gonna take that short poor guy
so we can sit down
he brought an ikea bag full of swedish
snacks oh my god i was wondering what's
the blueprint well before we get to the
oh you want to show all the snacks you
got go ahead should i yeah no i mean i
want to talk to you a little bit oh okay
well and then we can pass them out
so love is here all the way from sweden
you're here for three months right love
just about three months yep wow
what a thrill
do we have a shot of love
below his eyebrows oh
well he's a lot shorter than we expected
oh stop we didn't do it yeah okay oh
come on now that's done
come on now that's not nice
that's not nice
what's up
love you're here is this your first time
in america uh second actually i went
once uh when i was eight years old to
new york your mic sounds like doggy doo
doo one second something oh not good
you could work sucks first time in l.a
though eh
yeah first time in l.a absolutely
so far you and then you and cam are
staying together yeah you know you know
in a wall-less airbnb oh yeah super
weird
airbnb super weird place super sketchy
but i'm very happy to be here um
i'm very excited to spend some time with
cam too wait is it really that sketchy
the neighborhood are you just used to
like peaceful beautiful stuff no i've
been told
it is really bad
what is wrong with you dude
you can live already in the sketchiest
neighborhood and then poor loves coming
here from from beautiful crimeless uh
let's be honest we didn't even crime
this uh i just want your area must be
because i think you're the only person
who lives in like that county yeah
unless you unless you commit a unless
it's you're committing the crime yeah on
yourself i've had the worst experience
when he first arrived the first time he
got out of the car
there was pissed everywhere it was just
a rough well are where are you living on
skid row
yeah are you saying
robot
why are you living in skid row with him
let me tell the story so we had this
beautiful airbnb
two two bedrooms two toilets beautiful
kitchen and all that stuff
and the minute or i guess one day before
i was going they canceled on us how can
they even do that no
how could they slap
like what does that mean
that's yeah
yeah so i got kind of [ __ ] up for that
are you guys looking for a better place
yeah okay that's good in a month we're
gonna get a better place yeah
wait are you guys actually on skid row
because i wouldn't even want to what be
in five blocks of that place we are
within five blocks of it i think
this kid drove a huge spot how is anyone
gonna know that they where they live
not i didn't say where they live skid
roads like a whole block
yeah it's not that good but i'm i don't
i don't care
damn yeah don't walk around there at
night that place is straight sketch bro
the immediate area around there being b
is pretty good okay that's good yeah
yeah there's one spot in l.a called skid
row
which is basically
like hell on earth i mean i don't know
how to describe it it's just it's just
it's like third world conditions
uh there's all the the addicts and uh
it's just like and prostitution and just
it's just like lawless wildness
great for a tourist
it is interesting a great first
impression
well it's super weird because during the
day it's like there the areas
immediately surrounding skid row there's
a lot of nice restaurants and stuff and
during the day it's nice well all of la
is like that it's like block the block
it can be
super ghetto and then all of a sudden
really nice is just very it's true
neighborhood dependent
when we got there because me i picked up
love from the airport the door was open
at the airbnb
we just walked in and seen guys like oh
i just i'm just cleaning here i'm like
oh we're looking for the owner and then
we waited around for like another 20
minutes some guy walked up he's like oh
i represent the owner i'm like okay
i represent him i'm like what the hell
is going on here
yeah
it was interesting you got a nice thick
thick door there
no it's really oh [ __ ]
they didn't even give them sheets
no [ __ ] what yeah how much do you pay
for this five dollars a night you better
be no i pay a lot bro can you guys say
the price it's very expensive so
tell me the price
it's like over 4k wow but we split it
for how long
one month
really what the [ __ ] failed on 4 500 a
month
yeah dude
because all the airbnb oh wait wait hold
on you could stay in a yeah that's 150
and i mean you could basically stay in a
hotel at that price hotels were a bit
more yeah
but we got [ __ ] last second that's why
we couldn't get anything better yeah
that is pretty expensive to be honest if
i could just give cam some credit we've
been making some jokes but his actual
his first air b
it's not over yet it's the it's not
so he's renting too so he could stay
with locals oh man
cam is the man
anyhow
that's crazy
you guys don't have a fantastic job
you've done a fantastic job we're so
proud
i'm going to help you guys out when i i
got to help you guys out talk to me
after the show all right we'll figure
out i don't i don't want you getting
stabbed on your first
on my watch i mean i brought you out
here i don't want you to die
yeah
so
uh you guys want something
so but i want you to speak this [ __ ] up
do you want to say about olivia by the
way because some people are oh yeah yeah
yeah so olivia
so olivia i talked about it on h3tv
the outdoor h3 tv i gotta explain
that's what i was talking about we gotta
hash this out oh that that i forgot yeah
that is
is taking three months to go back and
finish her school she was almost done
with school
and uh so she went back to i don't i
don't know where
i guess i won't say anyway
she went back to finish school
she'll be back in three months
you know and uh like uh back on the show
that's it she asked for three months to
go she's watching right now she is shout
out yeah shout out olivia please stand
up everyone was so sad that she'll be
gone for three months yeah sausage fest
again yeah
we got sam holding it down that's true
we have sam
maybe sam sam maybe sam could sit on
camera
if she wants to yeah yeah maybe not she
doesn't like two's wine i i like her too
but
at least we have some foreign sausage
now all right that's right foreign
sausage
um
yeah so shout outs to olivia we miss her
and but we will see her soon so f's in
the chat for olivia boys and girls i've
been listening to olivia the entire time
listening did we find one for love or
who was it we didn't find have one for a
b or love me and love but actually zach
you got something new
yeah let's hear it
maybe
a b
a b it's a disgrace to a b
it's a disgrace baby love is what powers
and sustains our country oh that's a
good one
so true exactly so true
okay so then the other thing we were
going to explain first of all guys i
want to urge everybody please please
please this is this is important
so we made the old h3 oh
i got distracted i was gonna say the
story
okay so the first week
the first two weeks i was getting bored
with my free time
and then the second week
or the third week i was like i saw a lot
of people being like damn post on the
subway like damn i'm you know
it's so sad without the the gang without
the crew
to entertain us
really kind of sad stuff and i was like
yeah i mean i feel the same way too and
there's stuff coming up i wanted to talk
about
so i had the h3tv channel which is where
we were our original plan for the
channel was to put i guess twitch
oh yeah right and then we're like we
don't want to do twitch so i was kind of
just sitting there empty and i already
had like 50 000 subbies damn why are you
subscribed like what the what the hell
dude
what the hell i subscribe to the h3tv
podcast the one that we're doing right
now well so what you don't you have no
allegiance only stuff you're involved
you're disgusted
so i started i was like you know what
i'm just gonna post i'm gonna post and
what's so fun and liberating for me is
that it's like i'm just doing a little
show
by myself
and it's so epic and fun
and i've been doing like two videos a
day i mean since i didn't have the
podcast i would just go in the basement
film
and it's been so fun and nice and the
people there are enjoying it so head
over to h3tv the channel
and subscribe because i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep trying to do like one video
at night it's kind of what i've been
doing instead of playing video games
it's been fun
uh but just to give you show you guys
kind of what it is
it's just me
reacting
and rehearsed
but this one is quite raw and weird yeah
i'm gonna do an update on this
actually but there's actually some
bangers in here that i recommend
if i can minimize this hello wait that's
a couple
yeah why yeah because they look like
brother and sister
no they don't know
[Laughter]
she has blonde hair because he is dark
hair
yeah anyways
when i saw the thumbnail i thought they
were well they the body language isn't
coupling because the it's a breakup
video
okay can um
how do i um dan um yes sir i cannot
minimize my freaking tab dude i can't
click anything
the navigation bar is totally out of
frame
i literally
am freaking out right now to come fix it
wait why did it
i saw it for a second
i am literally freaking out right now
what is happening i can't drag it
all right
okay
i'm back dan good luck i'm back
wait is someone hacking my main frame or
is that me
anyway there's some bangers here like we
made a cav cav
update and we made a um
we won the lawsuit video here
as well as a nicka cotta by the way did
you guys like this thumbnail i did like
the virgin
zombie kavanagh vs chad ethan
i think whenever i make a video about it
kevin i'm gonna do the chad photo of me
uh so anyway h3tv the channel so dan
you're confused what's your problem
so we have a show that we've been doing
for about six months on the podcast
called h3tv yeah
and then
there is another completely different
channel
that is branded the exact same way it
uses the same thumbnail
called h3tv
we have like
six months of sponsored ad reads sold on
a show called h3tv on one channel
it seems to me
like maybe the other one should
have a different name than than the
podcast i didn't i didn't say we have to
change the podcast name well at this
point i was like i like h3tv the channel
but
you're saying i forgot you want to tell
you want to get to the point on that
well i wasn't going to expose you but if
you're saying you can't do it
even in the chat
i love h3tv i forget how somebody
somebody brought up the podcast he's
like oh wait i forgot that's what the
podcast is called
it had been a while
but also the h3 tv for life i thought
that was our slogan over here on the
original h3 tv right now h3 tv forever
oh forever yeah totally different
don't get me wrong i appreciate what
you're doing it does seem like fun it
seems like a a nice little thing you got
going over there on that i hear a butt
[Laughter]
maybe just h3 reacts h3 no h3
okay no react whatever what about h3tv
dot tv
h3 tv tv
we'd originally floated the name uh h3
daily
issue daily because it's daily uploads
that makes sense yeah but then i have to
be what if i miss it it doesn't have to
be every day well
it's more about things that are like
daily news daily occurrences
age three daily
suggestions
cam suggested h3 tvb
h3 tv what b
the alt channel
h3 daily is not bad ethan
can we take a vote think about that
let's do our first straw poll of the
year
some people are suggesting throws theory
we'll get to the whole throat thing but
yeah by the way sam is our new shirt
live
i think okay here let me show you guys
in honor of kavanaugh ryan cavanaugh
obviously we won the lawsuit or one of
them some people may not know
the first motion the tortious
interference one the one about um
he's he was saying that i ruined his
business because of
that
review
well the judge said she threw it out
with prejudice
we are going to sue that mother
for attorney's fees and he's become
since then like weirdly freak obsessed
with the
with finding this guy throws
who's a moderator on wikipedia i'll get
to all this is like my favorite
well i don't know if i like that or or
the whole cucking angle more uh
both of them
are both powerful angles i think the
roast is picking up well the roast is
amazing
okay god i want to get ahead of myself
yeah
we have to tell this story
all right uh in the logical way but
there's so much to get to i guess i
better focus but sam can you
um link the
a383shop.com
[Music]
are we not at ad break yeah it seems
like we are 30 minutes but uh yeah so
for those that know we added a new shirt
to help with the funda lawsuits
uh i love thrust
which is available now at h3h3shop.com
uh guaranteed to piss ryan kavanagh off
but thrust is a free speech
uh hero we love throats whoever he is
whoever he is
okay let's focus because there's so much
to get to
yeah so h3tv we got to pick a name for
that but i guess we can do that another
time because we have a good jillion
things to get to right and we should do
i was waiting for a natural uh break but
why don't we do our ads or at least
maybe you want to do two and two today
let's do one two
i'm too excited to talk about everything
i can't do four at once okay all right
let's thank two of our sponsors
okay god bless you
ela has the bladder the size of a acorn
babel thank you to babel whether it's
saving more and spending less getting
organized or losing weight there's a lot
of worthwhile goals to set for yourself
this year the top of my list is learning
a new language with babel i was
wondering where they were going i was
like this is a language app right yes
uh the language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
ian was you were using it right or who
what are you learning french okay how's
it going
have you got past wii yet
beyond
good yeah
do you love the app
uh i'm i'm i'm learning things i'm
learning
francais
really getting that that noise down deep
you know
zac zack's learning too go ahead
all he says every day not only is
learning a new language fun and engaging
hobby you can use it while your check
off traveling more from your list the
whole babble process is addictively fun
fast and easy babble teaches bite-sized
language lessons for real world use
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for the lessons plans but babel
has lessons that were created by a
hundred language experts over a hundred
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective
uh with babel you can choose over 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps to
improve your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to the lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it has a 20-day
money-back guarantee
start your new language learning journey
today with babel and right now save up
to 65 percent off your subscription when
you go to battle.com h3tv that's
babble.com
slash h3tv for up to 65 percent off your
subscription
babble it's language
for life
and curology who i
personally use and love
curology is the game changing custom
skincare made for you by a dermatology
provider they'll create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals
whether that's tackling acne clogged
pores skin texture dark spots fine lines
or something else you start by talking
taking a short online skin quiz and
uploading photos and if it's a good fit
they'll ship you your formula right to
your door it even has your name right on
the bottle
okay
what is curology so how it works for me
i took some photos of my skin i answered
some questions about my skin type and
once i got approved they sent me a
custom formula made by the this
dermatology provider so it's the real
deal
and they sent me three products a
cleanser super light you know i love the
feeling of their cleanser like cleans my
skin but it doesn't really strip it of
the oil
uh so i clean my skin then i put on the
dermatology lube whatever that cream is
and then i put on their moisturizer
after that and i feel freaking fantastic
you know it's nice not to have to worry
about expensive dermatologists
waiting in line fussing with insurance
uh it's a game changer i love it did you
just gasp dan
i'll tell you why afterwards okay
get started so guys i love it give it a
shot i think it's an awesome product an
awesome service get started with
curology just like i did with a free
30-day trial at curology.com h3 pages
five bucks shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash h3 to
start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel anytime
this prescription is subject to
consultation thank you guys what's up
dan why are you gasping over there
[Music]
the other channel this is a suggestion
from the chat that i just happened to
see
either
dad's basement ugh
dad's basement who's watching like mom's
basement
yeah okay fine we'll twist on keem's
podcast no no no no i'm not my life is
not defined by keems what keemstar does
okay okay
huh that's basement that's why you guys
yeah i thought it was a good suggestion
or papa's basement
how about you're literally in a basement
unlike game
how about i do this one without dan
again without dancing
how about the after dark
after dark could be good yeah after dark
yeah how about just changing it to h3
podcast
i got a great one you could call it h3h3
productions
that's interesting
that's a good one yeah nostalgic
i too am a huge fan of ethan and eli
h3h3 productions
what the f wow oh he's got it that was
the quartering saying he's a fan let's
play that again zach was that ai
generated what was that two i am a huge
fan of ethan and eli h3h3 productions
you're gonna have to unpack what is that
in the context of that that's a real
sound bite
when did he say that he was i when we
were doing the content chord i i mean i
did a deep [ __ ] dive on oh that's
back when when everyone was like
yeah so that wasn't being i just assumed
he was just being sarcastic there but no
that was like
he's been a fan with the whole rice gum
situation when he talked about ela he
defended ela back in the day
he defended shout out
in a creepy way surprisingly he said
something like uh
the queen of the actually what the hell
you said
oh well she looks like she would
not be down with pissing in my basement
and i like a strong woman i knew it
okay so
where were we going um
basically god there's so much to talk
about and we haven't even made any love
how's the food in america do you like it
have you had mexican food yet
that's what i was the most excited or
one of the things i was excited for the
food the fast food all the unhealthy
food
disappointed yet no no i'm actually
actually the moment i landed i did ask
for fried chicken
and that's what i got when i arrived to
the office where did you eat it
no one remembers like i don't know you
just got it from a random place you just
got to go to popeyes or something
yeah i have no clue where it was from i
know we looked up like reviews online
and ordered it it was a local place
though i got it like a fried chicken
yeah i mean it was pretty good yeah i
reported it for behind the scenes for
the members so yeah yeah
is like super yeah we took away the
super bright light because my swedish
eyes wasn't taking it well
um
yeah
h3 underground h3 underground
i like h3tv the best sorry everybody oh
my god
i like it maybe they'll get some cross
promotion going on you why don't we just
call this h3tv podcast
why does the podcast have to change what
is the one that we're doing that we sold
a bunch of sponsorships on that it's
like dan's defensive about his show i
like that yeah
i mean this is hp
you're always been saying h3tv for life
yeah yeah and you've betrayed that i'm
with dan i'm just i'm just i'm just not
as bold as dan but i'm with dan how
about a h3 unknown
what am i on an unknown soldier what did
i die and everyone forgot what it was is
[Laughter]
but uh i think we'll get some h3tv plus
somebody suggested it plus xxxxx
and all that
okay we'll think about it
yes so anyway
we won the lawsuit that was uh
awesome a huge
huge relief i mean we we knew that it
was going in our favor but you know
these things can go either way
um as as as when any lawsuit it can
always go either way but
yeah
it was great we got a
we got a very powerful
um ruling
she said ish don't think so
dunked on them a little bit and uh said
bye bye
so basically at this point it's time to
sue for attorney's fees which i cannot
wait to get a check from them
we were joking that i want to check for
my attorney's fees and then i'm going to
put the check on a shirt
and i'm going to frame the check
i'm going to send a i don't know if i
can send ryan cavanaugh maybe to his
assistant so i'm not like
i'll send him a signed shirt with a
check on it
yes so and then the other i don't know
if we talked about how he was trying to
take down that does ryan cavanaugh look
like harvey weinstein website did we
talk about that
or was that happening oftentimes that
was during the break yeah i think it was
the h3 tv
show underground yeah okay so
cav cav
um the whole reason i'm i'm really
familiar with this process because there
was a bootleg website teddyfresh.net
yeah that was just scamming people just
straight scamming people and i'm not
sure even how they were searching up in
the search results i guess there's not a
lot of competition for teddy fresh
yeah i don't know but they were stealing
our images from the site
they're just putting up like products
using our photography and everything
and then basically
if you bought it you would get nothing
that was my i tried it just to see what
happens then i got nothing
i think awesome mcbroom probably was
running that
in reality you guys got scammed
well anyway so we had to go through a
really expensive long process to remove
this website that was literally
cloned our website was imitating us so
there's a lot there's a law
a cyber squatting law for when you're
impersonating a website and interfering
with their business where you can take
their domain over so we had to pay
lawyers it took a long time they have to
get a panel together of like copyright
attorneys to make a judgment and after
like several months maybe even six
months
ten thousand dollars later we finally
got the teddyfresh.net domain now
it's it's ironic because after a week
that was settled we got a the same
complaint we did on teddyfresh.net
against does rank kavanaugh look like
harvey weinstein this dude filed a
complaint
of a a legal complaint
saying that we're cyber squadding that
were
impersonating him what a lunatic what a
loser this man is and the thing is is
that if you don't respond to the
complaint then you then it's a default
judgment in their favor
so like there's a chance if for whatever
reason we didn't have the money yeah or
we didn't know that it happened or
whatever uh he could he could actually
have a good chance of taking over our
beautiful
website which is now number three on the
google search results
um which i recommend everybody type in
ryan kavanagh
click on the website is there any
updates here love or
no just familiarize yourself there's an
update coming very soon though okay
that's good
just familiarize yourself with the facts
it's good to always you know
brush up
on
on their similarities right
or differences more that's my their
differences
but
inappropriate so he he's so he filed
kind of like a for you could call it a
fourth lawsuit a fourth action against
us to take down our beloved website
oh and it got thrown out yeah the
[ __ ] on the same day then yeah
it got thrown out for being filed
improperly he can file it again my
attorney said uh but we'll see if he
does too much wine sorry but yeah i mean
he has no chance of taking over the
website it's kind of just a pathetic
attempt of getting it removed so anyway
that was one the tortious interference
one
and uh yeah
so one star if anyone if anyone wants to
leave an honest review of triller
um
like i have
then then i encourage that yeah because
he sued me for saying that and the judge
said
that's not illegal
yeah that's that's
that's not interference
i love reading the stuff from the judge
it's like
um
you said this and this and this and yet
you show no evidence of that oh man do
we have do we have wait let me see
do we have there was lines in it about
she's like there was a lot of defamation
accusations in there they're like
and when you're talking defamation a
statement is either true or false yeah
you said kevin hart was on the app
it is provably false that kevin hart was
not on the act and you didn't provide
any evidence yeah
i'm sorry but kevin hart was not on that
app
instead of giving her 800 pages of
reviews like they didn't provide any
actual
yeah so just to show you what losers
they are uh the judge allowed them to
add more evidence past the deadline just
because she's being overly gracious to
them
and she said limit it to 10 pages and
they gave her 800 pages of evidence
which was basically just a dump of
reviews and the beautiful irony is that
the judge and us started using using
those reviews as evidence against them
because they included positive yeah
right there was positive reviews there
was generic reviews right so the judge
was like this is a totally generic
review it was like it's a trailer rip
off i don't like it
it's a ghost town whatever and the judge
is like how could you possibly attribute
this
to the h3 podcast it's totally generic
like or to this affecting your business
like right there's that as a result of
the podcast it's just
i don't even think she got to that
analysis of the torch's interference
part because you to even get to like is
that
did we interfere with this business you
have to get to did i cause these reviews
and are these negative reviews or did i
tell people to leave these negative
reviews which and she's like he never
did
what was the other one where she's like
it's provably false
that the app wasn't flipped well yeah
the other thing is you say the app is
flipped as defamatory you yourself admit
that the app has had an inversion
mr and becca she called him mr back mr
beck himself said the app is flat
it's straight flipped bro
it is so awkward
do we not have those lines in here maybe
the excerpts from the
papers
um no i don't believe so i could add
them right now
ugh it's so awkward
well i did it i did it on the h3 tv
because i couldn't wait
but anyway
um
here's emily baker said on it
shout outs emily baker said ethan klein
defeats triller the anti-slap filed by
israel's russia is granted meaning the
case is dismissed with prejudice cannot
be refiled and klein can go after trilla
for all legal fees and costs which they
are entitled to based on the rolling
here's an excerpt
oh so this is a good one that she posted
statements concerning whether triller
falsely represented that comedian kevin
hart uses the app as a statement that
could be shown to be true or false
defendants me have put forth evidence to
support their their prima
facie whatever the [ __ ] that means
showing that this was a true statement
at the time the podcast aired despite
not having a presence on the trailer app
the description of the trailer app
stated millions of users had made
trailer videos along with stars like
kevin hart
the plaintiff has not put forward
evidence to meet its burden of showing a
likelihood of success what she's saying
your case is [ __ ]
and then she continues the statement
concerning the app was flipped is also a
statement that could be proven true or
false
was it flipped or was it not flipped
ladies and gentlemen of the jury can you
imagine you actually get jury judy and
this is the [ __ ] they make you serve on
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
was the app flipped or was it not
flipped
mr beck said it himself
flipped defendants have put forth
evidence that this was a statement
originally made by mr beck while he was
trying to record using the trilla app mr
beck observed that the app had flipped
the camera plaintiff provides evidence
that the app had an inversion yeah so
the plaintiff ryan cavanaugh yeah i
don't know why they did this
but
they sp their lawyer gave a statement
saying i think they thought they were
doing something because they're like the
app was only flipped for this specific
phone between this specific
so any other thing anything outside this
window is proof
that yeah
ethan klein is responsible but he but
ultimately all they did was basically
submit into evidence of their own lawyer
saying that it was flipped yeah
plaintiff provided evidence that the app
had an inversion problem
relating to the camera functions on the
ios
device thus because it contains an
assertion of fact it's not actionable
defamation
yes my friends
just remember what they're suing me for
defaming them because i said the app was
flipped and also because i said thank
you ian
they said he looked like harvey
weinstein anyway
easy dub
on to the next one so we have
the actual defamation lawsuit
and we have the copyright one which is
the big one
uh i don't know what's the status on
well the copyright one is do
relationships gonna take time no they
said like april or something
i think there'll be some things
happening later this month or next one i
don't remember that was the first one
that was filed right yeah right so i
imagine that has to be
well there's there's certain things that
happen that can affect deadlines and
stuff they're different court
the copyright one is a
federal court the
torsious was a california
court
yeah and so the the thing is that
because his newest lawsuit the
defamation one was like substantially
related to the tortious interference
because there's so much in there about
defamation and about specifically ryan
kavanagh
that we were like well let's combine
these and combining is a really good
thing because it saves the court's time
it saves the court's money he's already
familiar with this she's familiar with
the facts
it's a great thing to do to combine and
so what uh kavanaugh did the day after
they lost they filed
something saying we need a new judge
because this judge
is biased against us
she is incapable of being
really she's on payroll at the age
straight podcast is she throws is that
she is thrilled right now
she might be anyone could be really i'm
spartacus
yeah i made a joke on the h3tv the
channel
that i haven't explained frost yet i
haven't even explained that
there's so much here
gonna be like an eight-hour episode
oh love have you tried mexican food yet
no i have not well i do want to oh wow
i'm done i'm so i'm a little bit of a
picky eater so i'm a bit worried about
what are you
wearing with your eggs
like
vegetables
really there's no you don't have to
worry about that mexican i'm a
child when it comes to food can tell me
what you like spicy food tell me we
don't oh yeah i'm done to eat spicy you
don't eat spicy okay um like meat
nose
i can eat salad
beans
be no i don't like beans that much oh
you got a problem with mexican food then
my friend there's always beans in you
know everything maybe
almost yes yeah okay but they're good
beans bro i'll try it though you should
try you're in america live a little i'm
gonna try anything i got oh there you go
they're good beans
they got some good ass beans so you
don't like vegetables that's it or what
else have you had mcdonald's and onions
mcdonald's
mcdonald's is all he eats in sweden okay
in israel it's like shitty you don't
nobody really eats a mcdonald's so i
mean it's like a different experience
no it's a different experience it's like
bad bad okay and expensive like it
defeats the purpose
it doesn't make sense yeah
yeah it's horrible it's way better here
sam is suggesting the mexican food truck
now this is pretty hardcore mexican yeah
for sure it's spicy
i mean it's good you how are you a spicy
food uh i like spice a lot yeah i eat a
lot of spicy things okay when you eat
spicy food what do you eat
um let's see like
i don't know like asian asian food is it
really actually spicy yeah like really
spicy okay okay you'll be fine you'll be
fine do you like have you tried indian
food sure yeah that's also another spicy
yeah india love indian food so should we
get some spicy truck burritos yeah we
should yeah
we can have them try it on the show just
to see
so do you like steak or chicken or pork
what's your thing uh
i like all of those
do you have good toilet back at the
airbnb
there's no lock on the toilet that was
the first question i asked you
that was the first question i asked
yeah yeah we have a good toilet yeah
toilet which is good
the food truck situations
yeah it's a gamble you're gonna fit and
it is yeah you may [ __ ] but you you will
[ __ ] all right all right sam let's do an
order
sam says the mexican food is going to
rearrange your organ
i might be out for the rest of the week
all right so we should get him like a
wet a burrito burrito with a [ __ ]
nasty ass wet burrito baby dude i'm
[ __ ] myself
oh god
so funny
shit's coming out down my leg
oh god
so anyway what was that sam we'll get
some brut get some wetties get some
weddings
this gauntlet made me laugh what is it
um
have you had mcdonald's has given me
have you visited blocked vibes
because
that one time i asked
belle
bella
well
have you visited blocked
have you had mcdonald's have you visited
blacks
so anyway
what were we talking about
oh here yeah i am [ __ ] kavanagh
sam just good uh
just get love the most gnarly thing on
the bri on the menu
the wet the wedding get me a wedding too
with shredded chichi
no you need to get whatever i get yeah
let's get two burritos get me and love
the same thing wet burrito with shredded
chicken all right let's go and make sure
he gets like guacamole and sour cream
and all that yeah i love that stuff
[ __ ] shabang
hila you want something
she sent the menu
and discord
yeah so kavkav
um
kev kev took the l
you know in response we were like i
don't know this could go either way how
is this is he gonna back off is he to
get more aggressive
i had a theory he might back off because
after taking such a public and
humiliating loss
there might be other people invested in
triller
other people on the board someone with a
brain
who is like you need to stop this is
humiliating they're trying to go public
with this
yeah did you see this article i'm sure
you did because you keep up with all
this but
oh yeah
yeah of course i did
i'm glad that like hollywood reporter
someone's finally covering this yeah
title is triller's suit against
podcasters over troll reviews tossed by
judge oops dumbass
yeah um so and the whole thing is there
actually that's good
so i was so but in response to this he's
obviously doubling down and getting more
aggressive he had uh four more lawyers
or three more lawyers
for the defamation case so he has six
more lawyers he has three lawyers
applying from like north carolina or
something they'll hype that like super
famous uh
scary quote unquote lawyer
so three of the three people from there
are applying for permission to be on the
defamation case they're gonna have six
attorneys on retainer
against me for defamation
yeah
and uh
publicly he's had a lot to say about it
as well
let me see here
we got to do cav cap first
publicly he's saying
um
the first thing he did was put a bounty
a new bounty on my head
trying to prove that i am this wiki
moderator called throats
here's ryan cavanaugh this was
basically just of
the 15th so this was two nights ago so
this is fresh
he erased it of course because he did it
at 2 am meaning he was definitely drunk
and in the morning
he erased it
let's have some fun
and up the stakes this will be good fun
for h2 followers to guess what we do or
don't have
25 000 to the person who provides the
identity along with legal and verifiable
proof of throst and popoki 35
must be absolute
first person to provide gets paid
it's a race everybody
he thinks it's um squid games or
something
this is so
this is maniac behavior right here like
what a [ __ ]
idiot
this guy does what's weird is that he's
so eager to prove that so throst and
popoki are wiki mods that have been like
making sure his page stays factual
because he just wants it to be a fluff
piece and these mods i guess have been
uh well so he
he personally threatened throws yeah he
threatened with legal action that's why
he got banned and and i think that
that's why so whoever this throws
character is uh you know
he did it he did an mj he took that
personally and just made it his mission
to make honestly ryan cavanaugh's
wikipedia article be accurate i mean
that's all he's really doing
listen i won't even put that on him i
don't know the guy i'm not going to say
i don't i don't know anything about his
intentions i just know he's committed to
to the truth uh and ver and the ver the
the uh you know
factualness of of uh wikipedia pages yep
and he seems to have a particular
interest in ryan cavanaugh
who just happened to threaten him with
legalize yeah over nothing so yeah the
history between ryan and thoros is
pretty epic he threatened him with legal
action and then wikipedia banned him and
all of his like eight
sock puppets yes and he keeps making new
accounts and arguing with wikipedia mods
and keeps getting re-banned for sock
puppets the guy is literally
[Music]
bro i can see go back to dan's shot
it's funny you can just see love kind of
floating in the back there
and like i mean like i said
love is a lot smaller than i thought he
was going to be why do you keep saying
that
he's just like he's just like this cute
little he's this cute little guy dan
stop why are you why are you look how
small he is
oh you're making a joke okay
all right
it's in the palm of my hand
all right fair enough
[Music]
let's have some fun yeah so anyway he's
trying to prove that i'm associated with
the roast or that i am throat
but what's funny to me is who does he
think actually would have the
information other than someone on the
crew
so he's trying to bait one of you guys
to sell me out for 25k and i was like
first of all who would sell me out
probably ian for the right amount of
money i would guess you know i i people
were commenting that on my thing
dude you sent me a video of your dick
and i am locked tight i didn't send you
the video oh
yes
i'm the only member of the crew
long time watchers probably remember
this story you don't remember doing that
i vaguely remember i think and we gave
him a camera that had old footage on it
and we shot a dollar dollar club
you just gave me that sd card right
wrong right hand expect the dm from ryan
cavanaugh for that picture
that was wild
yeah
i'm sure that wasn't a flattering moment
for myself see i'm i'm a safe i'm not
tight that's true well what if rk
offered you like a millie if you had
that information that's what i'm saying
i mean that's life changing money
exactly that's what i was saying ryan
you gotta offer more than 25 000.
i'm spartacus he did listen to you
already because we started with 5 000
that he offered and you said you said
you gotta offer more and then he tweeted
that
still not enough though
how much to sell me out how much to sell
the cockpit
three million dollars just name your
price ian no no no no it's not worth the
headache and this guy in my inbox
all right true
10 million bucks to show the penis pick
oh you i mean obviously well i'm just
going to give ryan i do it
i'm trying to tell ryan what he needs to
i have that dick pic 200 gram
10 000 there you go i'm just saying i'm
trying i'm trying to get no this is
for ian's eyes
so do you have a pricey and i'm just
saying for ryan
no i mean i don't know you're tossing a
lot of numbers out i don't know we'll
see
he's trying to keep his leverage do you
have a price
to show my cop yeah to send it directly
to kavanaugh maybe
maybe i'll do it for free i just maybe
i'll just send it to him if he didn't
block me
then ian loses all his leverage
how much would i show my dick for i mean
i don't know don't ask me i
i don't know
i'm not that excited about showing my
dick i'll put it that way okay no okay
okay
i'm not running
i'm not running anywhere to show my
cough right now
so anyway that was the first tweet
um cav cavs new bounty
this was really weird he started
okay i'll skip this one
um he has undeniable proof revealed that
i am thrust
apparently
if he does why is he still asking for
evidence
well wait tc is evidence
so he has undeniable proof this is
someone he sent to someone and i've seen
this somewhere else so i do know it's
real this is real
someone sent him a notepad with random
ip addresses written down
he said i compared the last five someone
sent him this trying to get the bounty
which is so awesome i compared the last
five ip addresses from the wikipedia
account to his youtube channel h3
podcast as well as h3 productions i was
able to undeniably confirm that throst
himself is in fact ethan klein
and you will be able to see this for
yourself from this image literally just
a paint just a text pad with random ip
[Laughter]
awesome
the ip i think actually is in belgium
too uh a friend of mine sent me the ip
you can test it yeah yeah it's in
belgium it's not even like in l.a well
that's where your secret your secret
headquarters is
yeah i mean can you and like i don't
think a youtube channel has an ip dude
like it's just he's so dumb so this is
the undeniable proof he said he's had
and apparently and he's just sharing it
with some random person yeah he actually
is just talking with people in the dms
he's lonely
he's sad pathetic lonely man
too much wine sorry
oh
play that again zach too much wine sorry
that's kevin all right wait we never
played that on the show did we yeah i
think we just discovered there's been a
lot of kavanaugh discoveries over the
break oh lee
you know what else we didn't
play
on the show
was this amazing yeah yeah
oh is it muted i have twitter here is uh
and that is ryan cavanagh is the force
of nature it's ryan it's harvey
weinstein saying ryan kevin
is the force of nature
the horse of nature huh
hassan said is this the same dude twice
i said it's hard to tell uh to the
untrained eye but it's actually two
different people
i think it's important to make that
distinction i have an inappropriate
relationship with a fourteen-year-old
natalie portman oh can you pull that one
up
yeah
dude this was all over the break my
goodness yeah
but too much wine one is just gonna be
too much wine it's gonna just be
evergreen
yeah
um well why you fish that up baby
um
here is so he's been looking for throats
everywhere
people have been reporting that they
just changed their names to throws for a
goof and ryan himself has been reaching
out and direct messaging them
[Music]
um to the point where here is ryan
presumably on a shrek
i can't get over this fan forum how is
this possible
shrek wiki
found you 35. popoki around here
somewhere
this is a guy named throast on wiki on
shrek wiki
i throw shrek and you're in my swamp
hi cross pleasure to finally meet you
you've been a very busy boy
maybe we should talk sooner than later
such a like
i'm trying to be funny i think he's a
villain a villain
you've been a busy boy
unlike me
clearly
i have way too much time on my hands
um
yeah here is frank kavanagh
at the 2014 texas film awards where he's
saying he wants to have an inappropriate
relationship with 14 year old natalie
portman which we actually know he has a
weird obsession with i forgot about this
when i made my recent video
i was told i came here that it was luke
bason who was introducing me and i get
to star in lay professional too and have
an inappropriate relationship with a 14
year old natalie portman
so that's the only reason i came i'm
just joking um
dude he is so
[ __ ] blasted in this clip like look
at his [ __ ] tie he's like sweating
bullets this is just like he is [ __ ]
wasted man the only reason i came is
because i thought i would sleep with a
14 year old just kidding
first of all
too much wine sorry yeah so we so that's
our favorite sound bite of that
too much wine sorry we know we know we
know ryan
as long as you're not driving
right drive angry
so here's another dam of ryan cavanaugh
dm'ing a fake thrust account like i said
he's just been on the warpath to
identify this roast character
throst
i jokingly changed my usually him to
throw stuff or ryan accused someone of
the same name
of wic of editing his wiki after 48
hours of no response i received a dm
from kavanaugh himself among others
trying to get the 25k reward
hello
yes
that's it oh and then there's
it just says
he just says hello like trying to be
ominous
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
this whole story yeah
um
there was another one by ryan the uh
the wikilea isn't this old news or do we
also never talk about this we definitely
talked about this right wikileaks
28 days ago yeah or [ __ ] yeah i think it
was on the last week that we were on we
mentioned yeah he erased he raised all
of it he's given up
he was gonna make a documentary about
wikipedia bias
and he erased it he spelled credible
wrong yeah
it's awesome
[Laughter]
oh and then we also have by the way this
was something else that kept coming up
in our group chat right cavanaugh
fashion disasters you're like oh i love
it look how this guy dressed to red
carpet events
it's
what either can you give me an analysis
of this
i'm genuinely outraged and confused by
this
i god i i can't find the right words to
describe it flipped
definitely something's flipped
i mean it's like a five-year-old's idea
of how to dress right to an event i
don't know
it's like the the jeans are too long and
why are the jeans too long that that's
crazy to me
[Laughter]
first day of school meets bar mitzvah
ferris bueller's day off meets
city of hope
this is the city of no hope
it's the city of new york city yeah it's
a total bar mitzvah
that's that's dead on yeah it's like
[ __ ] i don't have dress pants
yo these jeans though they're so long
like he's rich like get like this is a
red carpet my dude is he's stepping on
them
totally uh here's from another angle
yeah they're going like halfway up his
foot
oh
yo
by the way the getty image person
actually took a picture of his feet
that's wild they literally said get a
load of this guy
he took a picture of his feet on getty
images can you believe that i never i've
never seen anything like that in my life
oh it bandaid wait why is he about
someone else don't notice
what does that mean oh my god
too much wine sorry too much wine that's
what it means okay so here's a different
event this is what he's wearing now
explain this [ __ ] i can't i cannot
explain this
what is this
first of all the shirt underneath
way too tight and light and like
shows everything should be a bad way why
is it why is it open
maybe this is later in the show when he
got drunk and he was like i'm just gonna
open it it's that time of night
looks like your uncle fester jacket what
is with the sleeves on this jacket
sleeves way too long
tight white undershirt
this is just a fashion disaster
what a nightmare
and then this was a recent one from
triller
what what the hell dude this one's no
excuse he's at his own event
imagine being like overweight i mean
he's a little chubby you can't wear
white dude when cheering i feel like he
thinks he's buff like in a way that he
can show off his body but like are you
serious i think so because why is he
wearing stuff like this all i see is
teddy dude
i think he's got a little bit
a little bit of a
you think he thinks he looks good huh i
do
this one seems funny look at the pants
again
it's got pants overflow wait what's
happening here there's like a bend a
wild bend
what is happening too much fabric is
happening i think it's too long again
taylor man
you can afford six lawyers okay this one
yeah check this out oh
what
this one is the best
you want to break it down here because i
don't even know where to start i don't
know i feel like i'm not good with this
i don't have enough like vocabulary to
describe
appropriately what i'm seeing but this
one's my favorite i can tell you that
the twilight look you think maybe
you think that's the way that it's
editing edward vibes or whatever his
name is like a twilight cowboy type
thing he's got rolled up jeans okay
who's the cowboy boots who folds the
jeans like that and have them chew over
and still see the socks too
but then he's got the same kind of
schoolboy ty bar mitzvah look
with a blazer over his jacket
does some did someone do this to him
this nobody would dress him like this
right it's so pale
and the way his pants are rolled up it
makes his legs look so short right yeah
can you zoom in on the boot area with
the sock you must have really short legs
because all of those
in like all of them his pants seem way
too long
i think he's just like got squat little
legs bro
and not believe what i'm seeing
i cannot believe what i'm seeing right
now when you wear a shoe like this it's
got to go under the pants right yeah
yeah
but he rolled it up to show it off
yeah so that's fashion disasters with
ryan kavanagh for me this is the worst
one really just because the jacket fits
so bad the undershirt is bad it's just
wow i don't know it's like are you even
trying like what the f
what is this [ __ ] titch
yeah
this one is pretty epic dude just
because they got the close-up of the
clue
so great
oh i wanted to show throst his post on
the wikipedia board ab about
throats was like can you guys need to do
something about ryan kavanaugh
perpetually threatening us every day
um it actually made me feel really bad
for those two guys
fourth roast
we stand with you thrust oh absolutely
solidarity
deep throat as i've been referring to
him yeah actually her source actually
i'm team
uh
kavanaugh
team edward
so good
twilight name anybody
i don't know it's somebody here twilight
movies yeah that's right i was going to
say somebody here likes it
yeah also like he's he's about to take
his
his um
this was a really interesting article
so somebody posted this in my opinion
a new ponzi why did they spell it like
wait why the [ __ ] did they spell scheme
like that you guys
uh i don't know
is that a goof or do they is that a real
misspelling skin maybe it's a goof
so this person said
you know what dude you spelled scheme
like that i can't read this oh no sorry
did you find that post maybe
i know i'm looking for right now it was
in the the document i sent you
i copy pasted you last night it was in
that i just it should be all right here
i just
in the actual doc well anyway moving on
you it's on the subreddit until you can
find it there
um
so anyway in honor of throws who's being
insanely targeted
by uh
by kavanaugh we have made this merge now
you can go to a stray street shop to
help support our lawsuit efforts
we still have two massive lawsuits to go
and let's just say we love throats
we love throws we are not throws but we
love thrills
we love that he cares about free speech
we love
that he
volunteers his time to maintain a
website we all use and love every day
who among us doesn't visit wikipedia
several times a week
so true and the roast is one of those
heroes you know there's just no reason
why he
ish and and popoki 35
should endure this man's
harassment shout out
so anyway um
yeah even the quartering defended me uh
with kavanagh i was very impressed
because usually when it comes to like
right wing guys everything i do is just
the worst thing that's ever happened no
matter what
even in this situation where it's like
objectively i'm right
keemstar is still finding a way to be
like
it's not it's copyright infringement
yeah okay guys
finally had to dig into the insane
lawsuit against h3 yes he keeps poking
the bear but who
seems to have a hobby for
uh poking the bear who seems to have a
hobby of filing frivolous lawsuits but
our differences aside these lawsuits are
bad for all of us and i back his efforts
to win i have to go puke now
guys what do you mean poking the bear
though like still it's like you mean my
constitutional first amendment
my right to free speech
to talking about public figures poking
the bear
i shouldn't have to expect to be sued
for talking for oh well maybe i should i
don't know some things are more
important than petty beef internet beef
okay fine
yeah but but not to give him too much
credit because he like literally one day
later was calling me
he said
he had a lot of words to say about me
jordan peterson is no more of a gateway
to the alt-right than you are ethan
deleting your interviews is truly a new
low
how many times has he used that phrase a
new low yeah so i responded with this
post from reddit i saw how do i convince
my husband that him pissing on the floor
is not okay and he needs to be
responsible for it
oh my god that was actually from the
subreddit
um
so that's i feel like there's more cav
kev stuff but i guess that's enough for
now i don't yeah i need to talk about
capcat forever yeah
i do want to show that post though maybe
i think you just i'm sorry i believe
this is it i was helping out with the
teddy fresh stuff and sounds a little
bit
and mia is this little flip a little
flip did you talk about is this one hit
right here because i just copy and
pasted that yeah this is it this is it
this is actually important because
what ryan's doing by basically putting a
bounty on them and harassing them and
threatening them with legal action is
he doesn't even need to figure out their
identity or sue them he's scaring them
he's trying to scare them
into
into um
what's going on are you showing it dan
i'm gonna read it oh i was like what
he's trying to scare them into uh just
disappearing i mean
it'd be totally rational for anyone at
this point to be like i'm i'm not i
don't be involved anymore right and then
let ryan put back his page to what a
great guy he is and everything's perfect
and he's the best dude ever
so this is a post on wikipedia
from throst ryan cavanaugh's tweeted
calling out specific editors popoki and
me again accusing us of having some sort
of connection to him being paid by a
third party after the tweet was
published there have been multiple
attempts by people to log into my
account and one attempt to change my
password that's definitely ryan is there
anything we can do about this sort of
harassment like perhaps imposing a
site-wide ban
on rk the user i wonder what that stands
for and his sock puppets who i think we
can now all agree is ryan cavanaugh
himself
yeah and then there's the top rank kevin
appears to have filed a lawsuit implying
wikipedia editors
or at least stop him from yeah so
basically i mean
he's causing a lot of trouble for these
poor guys and it's outrageous it's
disgusting
so ryan kavkap still at it that's it
that's all i'm going to say about him
out thank you
so next up we have basically
an incredible beef i had both you know
we were supposed to have a quiet time i
don't know how i got into beef with both
joe rogan stands
and jordan peterson as if they were
different people um before we jump into
another topic though we should do our
other two ads
got it
and we have the link prepared for
can you put it at the top of the dock
and i'll pull it yeah
um
what is this discord you posted in our
group
so anyway let's thank our two other
sponsors i want to try love swedish
candies too
so much freaking drama you guys just
i think let's have some fun
there's so much that happened
cleanser yeah we need a palette cleanser
yeah joe rogan and and jordan peterson
stands tried to literally kill me no not
literally but they
they i mean i was like big news i think
on twitter and uh
and they're big mad yeah big mad
i saw that jordan responded to you i got
to be honest i i did not follow the
jordan beef he was responding to me i
know and i saw that that was happening
and i was just like i'm going back to
work next week i'm just i'm just gonna
that's fine
so i'll be finding out about it as we
talk about it okay interesting so you'll
like it yeah yeah jordan peterson
actually started responding to me yeah
he asked for specific reasons why
i'm saying the things about him i
provided them he didn't respond to me
and then he posted an article titled
jordy peterson schools ethan klein on
cancel culture
he really schooled you huh you feel like
you were taken to school not at all he
didn't even respond to me oh weird
yeah
so um let's do our last two ads and then
let's do a vote on what do you guys want
because i don't want to boy with all the
if there's just like too much drama i
think we have to spread it time
yeah all right so thank you guys to
hello fresh
hello fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hella fresh to make some
cooking make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
number one meal kit
the new year is a great time to focus on
what's most important ah abs
glorious burrito
it's the new year it's time to pay
homage to the great burrito a great
hello fresh burrito
i sent uh a b home with a whole packet
of hellofresh asking him for photos and
this is what he provided us i'm very
proud of that there we go
it was good though right it was really
good nice
um
whether it's saving money by ordering
less take out learning to cook or
prioritizing your wellness hellofresh is
here to help with endless options to
make cooking at home simple and
enjoyable and hello fresh delivers
pre-portioned ingredients to your door
including farm fresh produce that
arrives within a week so you get
convenience without skimming on quality
skimping on quality skip the trip to the
grocery store saving you the weight and
halt long holiday lines and ensuring you
don't waste money on excess food i love
hello fresh they send you a pack that's
has like dry ice in it so it stays nice
and cold it sits on your doorstep you
don't have to worry about it going bad
if it arrives like in the morning
and it has beautiful fresh ingredients
it has a cut out with the instructions a
little bit of info about the food here's
some stuff is this from the super
troopers it sure is well that looks bomb
dude like a hawaiian barbecue flatbread
thing yeah and i mean the food is
incredible it's nutritious it's balanced
it's tasty
it's a fantastic way to have home-cooked
meals
it looks great it's actually a good way
to learn how to cook too i've i actually
picked up a few tips and tips and tricks
if you're not good at cooking uh it's a
great way to enter the door and if you
are good at cooking it's a great way to
save yourself time and money
that looks bomb i'll go to
hellofresh.com h3tv16
what's the 16 now why did it weather
always changing they up they upped it
everything was 14 it's 16 now we skipped
15. we skipped 15. because it's
referring to the number of free meals
you get from the promo oh there's many
worlds
it was 14 now and 16. wow
yes go to hellofresh.com
h3tv16 and use code
h3tv16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts
that's hellofresh.com h3tv16
thank you to hellofresh america's number
one meal kit we love you thank you and
finally
the good old reliable
lovelystamps.com
oh yeah
if you're a small business owner and
you're busy enough as it is you don't
have time to deal with the hassle of
going to the post office with stamps.com
you can skip the trip and never waste
another dollar a minute stamp.com lets
you print official postage right from
your computer so you can spend more less
time at the post office and more time
running your freaking business dude
that's right
stan.com about it dude exactly he saves
you time money and stress uh for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over a million
businesses stamps.com gives you access
to all the post office and ups shipping
services you need right from your own
computer and you get discounts you can't
get anywhere else up to forty percent
off usps 76 percent off ups those kinds
of savings are out of this world whether
you're uh uh in an office sending
invoices a side hustle etsy shop or full
blown warehouse shipping orders
stamps.com is going to make your life
easier all you need is a computer
standard printer no special thank you no
special supplies or equipment you and
you're up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to uh send
it to doesn't uh your girlfriend use
stamps.com it sure does uh she has her
little um
art business that she runs from home and
she does commissions and also sells
prints and everything and she uses
stamps.com
just got a little printer next to
computer the software it's got a little
scale just pop it on there prints out
the postage slap it on there postman
picks it up easy as could be so they
pick it up she didn't have to do
anything if it's a really big one she'll
take it to the post office but the
envelopes and stuff they'll just pick it
up wow that's amazing
save time and money this year with
stamps.com sign up at sebs.com h3tv for
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale there's no long-term
commitments or contracts that's sams.com
h3tv okay
let's do a fika
i think oh there's some funny videos i
wanted to watch too um
so let's do some fun stuff
there's actually some hilarious videos i
saw over the break oh keemstar went
after my dad too it's been so long
literally
that feels like it was forever ago but
we never talked about keemstar started
attacking my freaking dad on twitter you
guys
sorry sorry my dad doesn't care though
he's like my dad doesn't care about that
kind of [ __ ]
he's that my dad actually started
arguing with keemstar on twitter which
is kind of a parallel universe situation
i never expected
you guys want keemstar going after my
dad well let's watch some funny videos
um
let's see i go down the bottom
funny videos
there's actually a video i wanted your
guys's reaction to too it's so
rage inducing i wanted all y'all to
to give me your takes this was a post i
thought was hilarious um nicotto is
coming
next week dan yeah next week
that's right next wednesday wait is
there some nude no this is just text
right what are you
the guy who jerked off the nicocado's
nudes it's just text yeah okay
i hope so he said this is the funniest
[ __ ] i've ever read and preparation for
nick coming next week ela
i have masturbated to nick avocados only
fans and i am disgusted and ashamed of
myself
wait what
sat oh this was in sad cringe it's not
even our subreddit yeah
what is this it's a post inside cringe
he said title i was doing the deed after
abstaining for two weeks it first began
with normal material the average person
would deem suitable then i progressively
edged and got hornier as my session went
on i ended up
with me being curious and finishing off
the nicocado's nudes and when the post
not clarity hit i genuinely wanted to
kill myself it's been a few days and i
don't know how to cope with myself my
actions and what i did along with the
fact that i am well aware
and am the same person who did do that
oh i'm telling you
it's not that bad bro i don't know why
he's taking it i mean and it's pretty
pretty incredible that it escalated
from normal because i know i know the
kind of stuff that nick does it's like
straight gaper stuff
but if that's what you're into there's
nothing wrong with it i just thought it
was funny that he felt so ashamed
it's like
he went all the way down the rabbit hole
and at the bottom was nick
there's a wide hole yeah
that's that's a good one eh
uh here's some other funny vids you know
some ones that i found over the break
this is one i saw on the subreddit it
just cracked me the f up dude such a
great rescue video you guys
i don't i'm assuming it's where is this
is this like the middle east or like
latin america actually can't tell
let me see if i can find out
south america um
so the sirens blaring now the biggest
mystery to me
first of all this guy is not handling
the weight of that man well i could tell
you that right off the bat
um
what yeah oh my god
no
it's so
hey
i don't understand the plan here yeah it
was really funny there's the first
rescue team this is the the last rescue
[Laughter]
what is the flash the rope to the
rescuer yeah
and they just think they're gonna haul
him up while he's holding another guy
wow
just a single rope like
how is this supposed to work
[Laughter]
dude what the hell
i think
that was basically
what they plan i mean like i know that's
not what they expected but there was
actually what they they put one rope on
the rescuer and they said
we'll pull you but we're going to pull
him out
we show it again
also he's not in that deep of a hole
guys
that's why i want to see it again it's
like
just hand them off to someone up there
why you guys got to get over complicated
yeah like right where the people are
standing just reach down and help him i
feel like i could do that also the guy
that he's rescuing is wearing a hazard
like a hi-vis uh
jacket
was he rescuing somebody else is this
already the third round of this
i don't know man
i don't know but he actually bro i don't
know they're not it's not that deep just
it's like they've got a crane or
something that you're using some kind of
excavator to pull them out
give me the audio i want the audio
the siren is blaring someone's screaming
on a megaphone
the rope is on his you know right above
his butt
right now it's between his legs yeah
it's between his legs
what's the plan
[Laughter]
so shout out to the rescue team there i
see a comment that says these aren't
first responders they're last responders
glad you're paying attention to the show
abs
[Applause]
am i crazy or did i say that you did
i'm sorry i literally said that sorry i
was watching the other egg street tv
i got i got confused
as long as you're watching one of them
i'm okay with them baby did that
everyone saw that
oh and then here's another rescue
related video
that was so funny and i mean obviously
horrible but
first
at
a skiing resort
and
there was a lady stuck literally right
exactly on top
of it on a ski lift this one had me like
shooting those two things happening
exactly lined up is pretty incredible in
a freezing place yeah it's freezing
oh no yeah it did
what do you do
it's awesome isn't it
oh my god i mean i would take a i see a
vehicle in the background i would drive
the vehicle over that at least so it
wasn't if you're the person up there do
you just jump it's like i would just
drop definitely um but i think i mean i
don't know if they're older or what well
if they can ski they're not that
yeah
disabled right if you can ski
it's true it's very active
what a nightmare yeah that's awesome huh
and i think i'm pretty sure
that's so awesome isn't it
this is the visualization of bad luck
right pretty much
[Applause]
[Music]
how could it stop right
why me
how could it stop
right
over it
or i wonder if they knew the pipe was
burst so they turned it off and put the
[ __ ]
that put them right over there
oh man everyone's just watching like
well that sucks
[Music]
she was fine by the way okay yeah she
was fine
[Laughter]
they rescued her you know that or you
just no they do they
i do know that okay
here is the island boys giving a shout
out to a very special somebody
a very special island boy
right that's true wait um
yeah so you know they're pretty big on
cameo all right so it's been a hot
minute since i got celebrities to shout
out like ivan millat and uh rolf harris
so i thought i'd give it another go um
in the news lately galaine maxwell the
one who helped jeffrey epstein on his
island with all the massages and that
who is more fitting to shout him out
shout her out than uh the island boys
spiral stars let's see if they do it hi
g lane maxwell jeffrey wants to thank
you for all your help on the island
please keep it oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
dumbasses they literally they don't know
who g-lane oxwell is
i guess i don't expect anything
from them
um
this one was pretty incredible this is a
clip from the nba
uh
this was cold man this was cold this
newscaster what a well-designed play
and um
you got to give credit
kevin porter jr
like his dad
pulled that trigger
right at the right time
yeah okay so
apparently
so
apparently
his father spent four years in prison
for manslaughter
and was later killed in a bar fight
his father
nobody yeah hold on i like you got to
hear the whole story before
i go back and play it again it's the
craziest [ __ ] i ever heard
wait what's the back story i wish there
was more intel here
um
can you can someone get one
right now
because it's it was a really like sad
messed up story but apparently his dad
went to jail for kill for yeah he
created a 14 year old girl in 1993. so
what happened though was like an
accident or something weird let me look
into it manslaughter so generally that's
uh
i keep having heartburn by the way this
whole time
really you want some tums i'm sure we
have some in the outfit
do you think we do do we have a
heartburn medicine we have toms
somewhere oh you keep have someone else
bro yeah
so um
can someone grab tub sam
oh you got something in thank you
anyway his dad killed a 15 year old girl
i don't know what's the back story but
this guy's a well-designed play
and
you got to give credit
kevin porter jr
like his dad
pulled that trigger
right at the right time
[Music]
dude without an ounce of irony
just straight up like his dad thank you
you will pull the trigger at the exact
over there
so is this the guy ian who's making an
apology now yeah that's his statement
did he get fired
i don't think so
some more saying the fifth slide
explains
i thought it didn't give enough context
this one
i mean everything i'm seeing is just
saying what you just said he played
guilty to manslaughter and did time yep
i mean okay whatever there was a more
interesting story i remember
about why the girl died like it was a
big trap it was obvious big tragedy you
know what i mean
just like his dad
knew exactly when to pull that trigger i
want to sincerely apologize to kevin
porter jr and clarify last night's call
please allow me to take this helper and
surely apologize to him and his family
and the rockets organization i made
during last night's game i mistakenly
thought that kevin was the son of
forming former washington player kevin
porter and was unaware that i the chose
i wore the words i chose to oh
i didn't know that the words i chose
would be hurtful or insensitive i kind
of believe that because the way he said
it
seemed like he was saying it like a
compliment yeah right so he thought he
was someone else
whose dad was also a basketball player
oh
because the way he said it was so cold
it was way too cold
just like his father
knows to pull the trigger it's like what
who says that
yeah it makes sense there was a former
washington player kevin porter and his
name is kevin porter jr that makes sense
right makes perfect sense to me are we
giving him a pass
yeah i mean it was an obvious mistake
okay well
there you go
all is well that ends well
that's like o.j simpson's son
being like a football player
he really took that guy just like his
father really took that guy's head off
just like his father he got away with
murder
[Laughter]
i can't believe the ref didn't call that
foul
just like his father he got away with
murder going deep like that knife
oh yeah
just like michael jackson
people are still divided on the michael
jackson one so
i think they forever will be
you know look his music's great but you
gotta admit the dude slept in bed with
kids and a story
[Music]
just like michael jackson
that man just molested a bunch of kids
i'm sorry but to anyone still defending
michael that man slept in a bed with
kids what are the chances he didn't
flick one of those kids dicks at least
once
like zero let's be honest bro you don't
sleep in a bed with kids period i don't
care how [ __ ] adolescent and sweet
and innocent your brain is the minute
you sleep in a bed with another kid
who's like 10 years old you're
definitely touching his dick
end i'm looking at uab
what's up i was watching the other show
again what's going on yeah
once i change the name you guys won't
have that excuse anymore
um did you want to show the tf link
yeah yeah i'm getting there
so also speaking of ab wally actually is
[Music]
what's happening
i don't know what's going on
oh also i gotta say ab came through and
got me a badass christmas break
all right now he got me a freaking
xbox dude
i didn't tell anyone around here but i
did
yeah
pretty cool i want everyone else to know
where's mine i want everyone up there i
don't know man i was shanked for the
have you used it was it was it hard to
get no i haven't i haven't yet i mean i
was just i only got it a few days ago
okay my cousin's like oh
my cousin his cousin got one or he sells
them and uh he's like he has a few more
left if you want one i went to go meet
up with him
in this very shady house and i got it
let's go oh wait you got it from your
cousin your crazy cousin's friend no
different not my crazy cousin another
cousin my good cousin
thank you bro that was actually a really
sweet gift no problem at least i could
do
so what should i get should i need to
get halo so we can all play it again
yes go
start a clan
clan h3 tv clan
by the way there's a new teddy fresh
collection coming out on thursday
um
i'll just show it off a little bit
yes
yes
yes girl
hair clips
yes
skirts
[Music]
beanies
yes
brunex
is that our corduroy band corduroy pants
yes she looks great look at all that a
full tf look
that's
it's a hat
gila
loving it
we love it
don't we folks
stuck loading
um sheesh
yes sherpa
those are beautiful i love that sherpa
hoodie
gary kennedy socks
sweater oh more jewelries coming out
let's see
yes yes yeah oh fancy yeah
that looks good
those are the corduroy pants
uh women's
sherpa slash puffer jacket
nice i'm jealous i want that jacket
there's a lot of stuff actually and uh
check it out this thursday teddyfish.com
january
january come back
okay so
let's do the fika experience eh
yeah i'm curious i want to do a candy
taste test
[Music]
feeling very patriotic to the swedish
people right now
[Music]
so how should where should we start how
should we do this
yeah sure that's a good idea you guys
gonna try to yeah we'll pass it around
okay
yeah just just give it to me baby hey
thank you all right wow
[Music]
so here i'll all introducing you can
explain
you can i'll you should go back here
it's it'll be
wait this candy's already been opened
what the hell
wait what
you've been tapping into the fika is
this the good [ __ ]
cookie dough
oh wow chocolate cookies that is the the
good [ __ ] yeah
this is called marabou oh that's a
famous one right marabou yeah
maribel milk chocolate that's the best
chocolate that's good oh my god
i don't like the milk chocolate in
america
yeah yeah that's weird in america
fudge
fudge and sea salt okay we love it milk
chocolate too so much this is chocolate
which you know
let's see
this is paulie oh yeah
holy polyamory like
oh we never talked about cav cave
getting bold well i didn't want to
push you towards i thought he wasn't
sure if you wanted to go there well i
just wanted to do stuff in order
we found out that cav cavs wife is like
getting slammed by another dude
like undeniable why are you saying like
that
slammed
because he's like a bull his name's brad
he's like jacked and handsome he's the
antithesis of everything frank kavanagh
is
but
it's so funny okay let's stay on point
and then we can get into the
um this one is just chocolate right uh
no it's uh something else in the middle
oh my god yeah they're so good
one of my favorites no
that's valuable feat come on dude
i just don't want the dogs to eat it
there's two different kinds in that
pulley there's one with milk chocolate
and one with
darker chocolate which is really good
so good
okay
this is so [ __ ] good
i love this yeah it's really good right
this is like my favorite candy so what
is it inside
it says it's
it's some kind of really chewy
butter toffee and vanilla
wow that is so good
what's happening damn
hair
here take that one that one's amazing
oh my god
this one is poly
poly yeah
that is better than any american candy
annual story no way yeah
i told you swedish candy is the [ __ ]
i would eat more i'm just worried about
the heartburn
oh that is really good is that
the texture everything
the texture it stays with you no
wow
okay this one
i thought they were little penises but i
see those chest pieces now keep in mind
i bought this chocolate or this these
candies the day i
traveled here so they're a couple days
old
what does that matter it's sealed
well they're when you get them super
fresh from the store and open them
immediately they're super soft really oh
yeah yeah even candles a couple days can
what
oh wow not old they're just not don't
they they're on the shelf
yeah of course yeah
but
from the day that they're made
um
like they kind of degrade a little bit
okay i see what you're saying the day
off when they're made they're so this is
super hard
yeah
it says best buy 2023 i don't
know but i mean if you leave candy you
can get it fresh yeah i got it super
fresh yeah
this is good
this is like a really hard chewy
wow so those ferraris are very classic
swedish candy ferrari yeah this is some
good freaking my dude thank you dude
thank you you guys like that chocolate
one that one's insane nepali
is the best you know
elo i'm sorry but i'm gonna have to
enter a polyamorous relationship with
the chocolates
got him got him
oh so i guess i'll say when i posted a
picture of these on my story
a lot of people pointed out that the
candy isn't from sweden but
they might of them might be from norway
finland and we all share them right yeah
that's okay
yeah
it's okay
pimp them those are all right yeah
similar to ferrari sure yeah
yep um
a little weird aftertaste yeah they're
very chemical almost
very chemical yeah they taste a bit
chemical yeah
they're done those are horrible
i hate that really i like it
it ends just for horrible
probably forever
wow that part oh it does end like it's
just like battery after brought down
like a cleaning product i know
people like that
and some people do it's like a size
candy for some reason i don't know but
there's one bag that i sealed off
you see those bags that i sealed off
those yeah those i think is no one is
gonna like okay because they're either
uh a bit spicy or strong these are
considered candies yeah this one says
salt on it that doesn't sound like a
good candy let me see oh they're green
screen um they're salty
it doesn't matter i think
how is that a candy that sounds like a
nightmare they're good inside but very
salty outside yeah yo one of them tastes
just like swedish fish
yeah is that the pimp ferrari yeah
they're probably
the ferrari the pimp tastes like dog
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] mouth i hate it
all right so this one's called superstar
yeah so i don't think you're gonna like
that but if you give it second either
but if you give it if you get over the
salty face
then it's good
a little torture a little pain low
pleasure i mean this looks like a really
disgusting thing it looks like a weird
vitamin i like those a lot have you ever
had air heads here or not your head
a tom or yeah i know what you thought
yeah i've had those shower heads all
right
i've had those here you like those
i mean sure all right here goes one salt
one
stone of salt which apparently candy in
sweden super salt
[Music]
it's kind of good right
[Music]
i don't know if i'm ready for it
i'm trying to work through the paint but
it's still [ __ ] gross
[Music]
nope
you better you got everyone gotta try
one of those should i try or is it too
crazy
mm-hmm
it's not getting good yet love oh god
i i warned you guys bring it up
i chewed it it's really not sweet in the
middle it is
i can't do it
i hate that so much thank you
i'll have one now
yeah i don't like it that's the worst
thing i've ever done my tongue is
literally burning
oh
ugh terrific
yes
the worst
i think they're pretty good
there's no
need for that
oh my
god no way you like this it's like dirt
dude
it doesn't say that it tastes like
[ __ ] dirt i got a glare
those are some of my favorites you
promised some of your favorite
the ones that is
right now
are those the non-stop
dude
never stop
those are so good yeah you guys are
gonna like those i've had my eye on that
that looks good
i need that an everlasting gobstopper
that was the worst thing
never stop
those are the same kind of chocolate as
you guys ate before yeah
yeah man they didn't taste good
have you eaten fish food
yeah like that's what this tastes like
you know it's a bit of licorice in there
this is that's where you guys i love
this yeah it's okay it's like an m m
yeah it's like good they didn't store it
and be consumed this is the worst thing
don't ever eat this [ __ ]
it's just salt on the front it says
super salty swedish
it's not a candy it literally says salt
on the front dude that's literally the
worst thing i've ever tasted it's
horrible
horrific all right back into the the bag
of horrors yeah this one says sour
not super sour
all right but those are better i think
because there's no licorice what's with
these extreme challenge candies aren't
we supposed to enjoy candies
well that's why i segregate to them
because
it's got the same shape like a hall's
cough drop
it can't be worse than a warhead right
um probably
yeah you're gonna like them though
i know i'm unusual but i i'm sucking it
hard
love warheads
i'm just getting into it
shredder is walking out might need to go
potty did you try the salt walking out
he's over this he just quit did you try
the salt manila the salt is the worst
thing i've ever tried ever the sour's
not bad warheads are way worse but
they're pretty tasty too those here
you're having now
they're they're tasty they're not only
sour
i wouldn't say they're tasty honestly
really
no i love sour candy let me try
doesn't justify the means on this one
i really don't think so
oh my god super sour
i can't get over that other one
the salt boy yeah you guys shouldn't
have the bad ones i admitted some of
them are bad
that one tastes like uh when you jump in
a chlorine pool and you don't plug your
nose
you like this
nice taste the worst fee
yeah the worst it's just the worst
experience basically
yeah they're all different tastes all
right next up from the bag of [ __ ] we
have
see these i don't think you guys are
gonna like one bit
it's called the
turkish pepper yeah what's pepper mean
pepper
it's not the right spelled it's not the
correct spelling but it's like turkish
turkish pepper
oh
it says soft and salty those are guys
[Music]
you shouldn't have it it's bad i'm not
i'm gonna skip the bad ones i'm not
going to eat a whole thing though
let's get half it's too long
texture is nice
this is amazing it looks like licorice
it's licorice so you like licorice yeah
oh it is like crushed hold on this is
great okay i will try one there's
nothing wrong with this
the one that looked the most deadly
yeah it's sweet i know this yeah we have
this in israel too oh yeah it's like
it's a little salty but it's still sweet
right but don't do do you like the salt
in the candy or no
i mean there's too much salt in there
because i like when it's getting salt in
the candy oh there's so much salt in
that i like it but it's good i like
those two you like that
yeah
okay
plus the only surprise i was expecting
yeah cause those are the only ones i
don't like from there really yeah
up next we've got
from the bag of [ __ ] it says salty
sour and what's
up tea
fish nutter i actually can't see what
fish is
but does it say soup
there show me again
salt sit sear
um
i don't know s-o-t set sweet oh oh sweet
so salt sweet and sour that sounds good
to me
here we go it says
[Music]
it's banana banana
but in swedish you say banana banana
but no okay yeah let me tell you about
but now
[Laughter]
i don't like the color like you try it
pass this one around then you guys try
it
that's the worst one this is actually
the worst that's worse than the fish
that's worth it oh i just i can
definitely spit it out i can
cannot do that and then
that's just the it's just not okay why
do you guys
[Laughter]
freaking girl
what the [ __ ]
do you need to crunch i don't think i
fit
i can't even swallow my spit it's like
but it disappears in like two seconds
i'll work through it am i supposed to
crunch it love
when you crown fit you you're going to
get the second surprise
oh
wait that means what's the second is
there's some goo inside
i'm going i'm going for it everybody's
going to the bat the crew is gone
i don't know
there's nobody left to even oh ian
you're still there
did you try it again yeah i'm sucking on
it crunchy then crunch it
it's not great
what's the surprise i just pulverized it
salty there's more salt the [ __ ] love
dude
this some of this candy is some of the
best candy i've ever had and some of it
is
the worst
thing i've ever tasted in my life
you guys are a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah just wait till the mexican comes
it did actually it said oh
that is [ __ ]
[ __ ] whoever made this candy the [ __ ]
you love hey no
this is the worst candy ever made i
think the danes made that candy actually
we need to invade
we need to invade yeah i think so too
actually take over denmark yep
we have one more
oh no
oh my goodness i forgot about those
this everyone should take one at the
same time and we'll see what happens
it's called
it's called jungle
junior
what does that mean jungle scream
all right everybody it's another all the
ones that say salt on it have been
resources we should take all these uh at
the same time
okay okay
everyone grab a monkey so this is a
licorice
topped with super much salt why the uh
all right well i'm not a fan of licorice
so that's alright so ethan if you get
over the salty period you're gonna
probably like this one is it a black
licorice uh yeah black licorice
i don't actually like black licorice at
all but i like to suck on these for the
salt
what are you a horse horse yeah yeah
okay
what's with your sweets you need salt
licks or something yeah we need like
extra salt
all right i'm still i ate one of these
polly's in it those are bomb though
those are really good the police
okay
are we all doing this
ready guess so
oh
it's so
intense it's so so
salty i can't
yeah i could i could season eggs with my
spit right now
oh yeah dude the [ __ ]
i'm actually gonna spit this one out
because i don't like the effort taste
are you bringing us candy that even
you're spitting out yeah i brought you
the whole experience dude what's wrong
with it oh my god what's going on in
sweden
what is happening so
i think they're all so you know what i
just realized socialism
will never work
right yeah they're not socialists
but this is what a smelling salt tastes
like it feels like that right this one i
don't mind is yeah
i mean i was able
the last one was worse because yeah spit
that out immediately that the flavor was
worse this is very slick
but that's the saltiest thing i've ever
tasted guys i hate it so much
it's got that dirt taste again
right it sucks
oh nightmare spitting this one out too
yeah you guys don't like licorice either
i guess so
basically
these just seem like candy bars are
these anything special love uh they're
lion you can have they're really made by
nestle how bad can it be
those are good those are one of my
favorite candies so i think you should i
have a bite at least
if you wait
yeah
oh just a good candy bar
bomb it's pretty good right yeah
all right now sam bring up the mexican
for a lovely track yeah i'm done sure
i'll eat anything
get them a nice spicy bite are they here
we just we'll have you try it
since you've never really tried mexican
food before
pretty incredible thank you
oh [ __ ] it's juiced up dude
it's a wet burrito can you try to show
it to the camera oh what's up
it's green screening out the salsa
yeah do you even know what you're
looking at look at this that's correct
so i'm supposed to eat with it with a
fork right here yeah okay love do you
know what you're looking at no i have no
clue
you know what tortilla is i i don't know
the difference between the tortilla and
burrito
you know the difference between tortilla
and what burrito oh the tortilla is just
the wrapping
oh so it's a tortilla
it's got probably like beans and rice
and chicken and salsa and guacamole okay
it's all wrapped up in there and then
they pour salsa on it
what was it on or at the end what did
you say at the end they pour salsa on it
oh i see what so this is guacamole
right some
can we get the camera down a little bit
yeah let's get a shot here there's a
bunch of peas on top too oh yeah
so it's not dive food i'll tell you that
right now so is this enough
oh yeah that's a big bite
[Laughter]
so why would you eat a
wet burrito bro because you have to find
out
basically the theory is that you put so
much salsa on it already you might as
well just drench it dunk it in yeah dunk
it
it's definitely a decadent food it is
not necessary
love took a bite
this is tasty man he says it's tasty
i feel the heat though
feels the heat
go on for a second buy it
i'll explain this
okay good
[Applause]
like this
crispy [ __ ]
there's a chip in there it shouldn't be
like it's just uh
like a ship that's just the way it is
bro
chilaquiles is actually a dish
filoquitas is a dish of basically soggy
chips okay no i mean the taste is really
good okay we love that so is this
chicken in here
yeah
is what chicken in there yeah yeah
there's so much sauce i don't know what
i'm consuming
drink it
eat it
get in there
get weird
welcome to america
how long we've been going dan
[Applause]
uh we've been going about two and a half
hours should we go down the [ __ ] hole
before we go the cockhold
the cold the cockhold the cockhaul
should we be talking about this i feel
like something else no i mean we already
brought it up i know but it's just like
i just feel like we already did a lot of
kavanaugh right
yeah i mean
it's like a king shaming
but it is interesting it's the wildest
wrinkle
so i'm like i want to talk about it but
also it is people are surprised by the
wet burrito i mean that's like it's
american mexican food i think it's more
california or maybe california
i know in mexico they don't even really
make a burrito at all no
no the burrito doesn't it's
la food more than it is mexican food but
i mean
it's real mexican food the people who
make it are mexican i mean this is a
mexican-american food yeah
so if we can talk about one other topic
what do you guys want to hear
you want to hear keemstar going after my
dad let's set up a poll
for addition one more one last topic
okay
keemstar going after my dad
kakana
keemstar versus gary
yeah
ryan kakana
joe rogan fans
want or try to cancel me
and then jordan peterson fans try to
cancel me i guess
two separate ones i'm not
taking a year to go over all that [ __ ]
and then there's ace family click
baiting their son
getting hurt
i can only do four hours so that's it
and then there's logan paul lost but
this old news
[Laughter]
okay go ahead with it let's see
yeah i'd be happy to talk about any one
of those topics
[Music]
you do eat burritos in mexico okay i
mean i don't know we've spent some time
there
i mean we've visited a few times
usually it seemed like the burrito
wasn't a thing
there's a lot of um
tacos yeah a lot of times the taco is
very
popular in mexico
uh looks like
keemstar versus your dad seems to be uh
running away with it
that's pretty juicy i gotta agree
[Music]
almost almost fifty percent
wow keemstar vs gary klein
taking a huge dub okay fun
yeah i'd love to talk about this i mean
it's super interesting
so let's pull it up
um
okay [ __ ] okay babe
so sorry uncle brad another
time brad the ball
so yeah um basically let's let's pull it
up let's take it from the top
um
roll it
so roll it i don't remember why he went
after me if there was a specific like
or we were making oh i think pretty much
the moment you got banned on youtube
keemstar decided he was it was fair game
to just like
talk [ __ ] yeah and i thought it was
pretty funny how he got real comfortable
the minute we went on break yeah like a
lot of the characters came out the
woodwork and all of a sudden it felt
really comfortable to say whatever they
wanted about me and my family in this
case
so yeah keemstar basically one day after
we started break
ethan klein's father from h3
um is trying to take basically
my dad by the way is like the most woke
libtard of all time i mean he is so far
left socially and politically
it's kind of laughable but keemstar is
trying to take him out of context to
prove that
i'm somehow a hypocrite or something or
that my dad is a racist
somebody said what a discouraging day i
have terrible luck with airports and
cops pulled over and written up four
times for offenses my dad said and you
don't even look black
of course look my dad is a [ __ ] i
wouldn't type that but obviously his
joke is that
black people get you know targeted more
right
um
but he's a boomer this is from 2017
so i guess keemstar realized that he had
already come through all of my tweets
and then he's like i can go through
gary's tweet
and try to embarrass ethan
also he kind of has the thing for
messing with the elderly he's done in
the past as well right
right good point it's only a matter of
time before he accuses
did he was he just like scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling through gary's
he's like yeah he's like yeah [ __ ] up
this old man's christmas
yes that's literally what he was doing
weird
so he goes ethan klein fathers from h3
podcast switch and like let's be honest
it's not even that good of a find bro
it's just kind of weird and pathetic
don't you think
team stars shut up to be tweeting out
like deep weird cuts from my dad
obviously he knows what that he's not
making a racist comment
also i mean whatever your dad is saying
is not you saying it
why are we even focusing on your dad's
twitter from a few years ago he's not
even a public figure he has two likes
yeah two likes
yeah i mean he probably had like two f
or like five followers or something back
then but not that it matters he didn't
say anything racist it's just
say ethan glenn's father from h3 podcast
um
there was something that led up into
this i can't remember what
bonus found by nicholas diorio shout out
um can you put up a picture of nick
while we read this one found by him
sure one second
hold on but wait it didn't start with
this stuff it started with him talking
to like porn accounts you know
there's it's all in here okay
um this is nicholas diorio okay hold on
i i'm gonna do
this in two steps
here's how nicolas diorio depicts
himself on the internet
right
that's some kind of he doesn't show his
face
well he does he just not on his channel
and then um
this is like keane's uh error to drama
alert apparently because he was posting
uh
videos on the dramaalert channel
here's what we're dealing with here
well besides him just being like a child
he's like so i mean he looks like he's
barely out of high school or still in
high school i mean he's a young dude
yeah this is what i mean yeah you argue
with people on the internet and you get
charged up and you've got to realize
that you're probably talking to someone
that looks like this
and what i mean by that is a
pimply-faced kid who you know he's just
he's a no-nothing
yeah
these are the people you got to remember
what's going on on the internet like if
i met this kid in real life i would
literally just
you wouldn't think twice about him
yeah i mean this is nicholas diorio
that's a good one
with
what was it weekend at bernie's what's
that movie
uh yeah weekend at bernie
and again not um listen
cool guy
exactly so this is the kind of person
that uh is a tough guy on the internet
you know so shout out to
shout out to uh at least keemstar shows
his face and you can you can goof on him
for his face oh maybe he's saying he's
24
really i thought he looked like 17.
maybe it's the older photos we saw where
he was maybe this one is from
it says
this is relatively recent
like within the livestream he looks
older on this one yeah he looks a little
bit older that's true but anyway my
point is you know it's like
yeah
so anyway shout out to nicholas dior for
shouting for digging up dirt on my dad
who's body shaming anyone i'm seeing
people i literally didn't even comment
on his body you got you guys are
projecting a little bit here
ice didn't say a single freaking comment
because you said that he was pimply what
you said that he was pimply i guess is
that body shaming no pimples saying his
pimple we all had pimples my partner is
that he's a child that he's a child yes
yeah okay guys am i not get let me ask
you something am i not allowed to talk
about anybody who's over like what is
your point
then nobody's allowed to talk [ __ ] about
me i'm fat don't say anything about me
dollar tree's scarce exactly
guys i didn't body shame him come on
not a single comment about his body he's
youthful he's got pimples he looks like
a child i mean what the hell
i know i already see that ethan is a
hypocrite he is body shaming
nicholas diorio
from the best gift of the year
what they said they're gonna he fed the
birds
they're gonna have videos for weeks now
or whatever yeah i don't care don't be
watching it sound like the nobody watch
it either way there's gonna be videos so
whatever
no i don't care but i just wanna let it
be known that i am not body shaming him
and i never said a single freaking peep
about his body so don't be acting like i
body shamed you bro
thank you
all bodies are beautiful in there
okay
i mean
well why don't we show what the oreos
sent to keemstar so
let's see
um
are you at least eight wait what is this
oh wait what these are wait these are
super out of order dude like
this is keemstar being creepy on his man
because i know he accused my dad of
being creepy but
these are all old keemstar tweets yeah
everything everything about your dad
should be in their first the first link
is there more and i didn't see it
yeah there's more
okay okay i didn't know that
okay so got it
so shout out bonus found by nicolas
diorio are you more enthusiastic with
your i can't read it because it's cut
off let me see maybe is it down here
let's see
[Music]
oh yeah here it is are you more
enthusiastic with your bj's they're
disappointing still because you're so
far that's disgusting
i mean and what's well
first of all
my dad is disgusting i can't believe he
was writing those comments on twitter
that is just so freaking embarrassing
but here's the thing that they don't
they don't
get is that
i am calling my dad out for being a
creep consistently oh no i don't know
you did it on the show with them we
counted literally how many porn accounts
you followed on twitter
so they think they're doing something
it's like maybe you should just admit
that you're a fan and you watch the show
because we already did this
but yeah that's disgusting i mean i
agree
just wait till we look at your tweets
keemstar
but wait this was i think we're not
remembering the context because what was
this following
he was trying to say that your dad is a
creep because we were talking about
someone else i agree there was what was
that text
bro i don't i don't even remember does
any of you guys remember we were talking
about someone
um that was
actually doing something creepy maybe or
or was it just keemstar maybe about him
dating
dating
oh yeah yes i made a joke about keemstar
dating a 20 year old right and then he's
like really well your dad was coming on
a on a 20 year old porn stars account or
something well i think we'll get there
to it right it's a little out of order
uh so
this is a picture of a girl posting
herself
with my face over it your ass does not
look busted well see he's just being a
sweetheart there isn't he
2014. he thinks this is
dude nobody's embarrassed by this i talk
about it my dad doesn't care
smash that like button i mean i wish he
didn't i keep calling him out for it and
he doesn't stop well this is from 2014.
i think he's stuck
this is really old i think he didn't
know even that it was public no
definitely not yeah
uh ethan klein from h3 podcast keeps
bringing up that i dated a 20 year old
as some kind of own when his own father
publicly sims for girls in their 20s bro
are you really dumb
to think that that's first of all the
same first of all you're talking about
my dad who i i already call out for
being a creep versus you actively
being in a relationship with a girl who
just finished high school someone who
has spring
yeah i don't get it your dad is not
trying to date anyone no in fact he's
only consuming their service yes they're
put themselves out there for that
purpose and he is in
on a public forum and he's engaging with
it and it's not to say that we like that
he's doing that we've told him about it
many times not to do it and i think he's
learned but
this is not the same way wait this girl
is 26.
she's not even like dude you're okay
that's but it's not it's just not the
same i so when girls put up porn is
there an age limit of who is supposed to
watch it or interact with it
it's 18 plus no no no but no i don't i
mean your dad is technically
like you said consuming there's
certainly a product that she's put out
there he's not trying to actually be
with her in person yeah it's such a sad
but and also i didn't do it
keemstar uh i'd oh god there i could go
in on him so hard but it's just below
i'm so [ __ ] angry i'm so [ __ ]
angry
i mean you say what you will about my
dad but at least he didn't [ __ ] leave
me in a dumpster behind a fire station
let's [ __ ] go
wait okay i'm just saying like if you
want to go after my dad then it's all on
the table right
i mean bro this guy text and he messaged
you two years in a row on christmas
talking [ __ ] about your wife saying he
slept with your wife
talking about your son talking about
your father
with peace and love
i'm going to be quiet now yeah thank you
yeah game star tried to no he's trying
to say my dad's a creep he's okay at
least he's in my life thanks for
reminding me he tried to say that me and
him were like oh yeah he tried to make a
rumor that you slept with him when he
was doing our podcast yeah it's not that
i slept with him it's that he [ __ ] me
you know it's like more degrading it's
not that i slept with him oh they were
he got me
him and leaf and all teams little
lackeys like nicholas diorio and our son
is technically his son which is
like i've never puked in my whole life
but this might make me puke game star
yeah exactly the guy's total scum but
i'm just making me like he's going
i could at least defend my dad by saying
he didn't abandon me right in a [ __ ]
gift basket to uh
you know the neighborhood uh orphanage
i mean i'm just being real
if we're gonna talk about each other's
fathers like my dad has a lot of
shortcomings but he didn't [ __ ] leave
the family neither did my mom by the way
i mean i think that's fair to say is it
too is it below the belt and i can't
wait to if you're saying it with the
point that
it doesn't make sense to go after each
other's fathers
if he has a point if he wants to say
who's the worst dad i mean right you
know
i'm sorry i got to defend my dad here
you think my dad didn't want to leave
the family
suck it through
not once
animals die
don't feel bad for keemstar he's
actually the trashiest worst human being
ever he literally tried to make a rumor
that people were believing that he quote
[ __ ] ela when he was here doing the
podcast and he made multiple videos
about it all of his sick through my
stomach to just hear that he reported
that leafy made a video saying he [ __ ]
he was actually trying to make it a
thing yeah and his his followers kept
trying to make it a thing
while also calling you a horse
yeah so she's gross but i [ __ ] her
anyway
yeah he's disgusting
he's gone after my dad my wife
and i love houses
this gang that talks [ __ ] nonstop is
gonna act so sensitive now i can't
believe what ethan said right
i am so outraged that ethan would make
fun of keemstar for being an orphan
orphan
cobra kai baby no [ __ ] mercy
well
i i really don't care
yeah i'm ready to join cobra kai
[Music]
sweep the [ __ ] sweep the [ __ ]
listen he made fun of my [ __ ] dad i
wish i could make fun of his dad i just
don't know who he is and sadly neither
does he
i mean
we're not [ __ ] around this year
i'm just saying it's and it's not it's
not keem's fault it's his dad's fault
for being a deadbeat yeah
there you go that's that's important
you can't blame the kids for what their
parents did it's not his fault he was
left like a [ __ ]
where's your daddy
where is his dad
yeah where is his daddy
so anyway that's basically that so
anyway uh h3h3 from it keeps bringing up
that i dated 20 year old but his dad
watches porn can you believe that
your girlfriend has braces
it's over like why just don't bring up
any of this like if you're dating a girl
with braces just don't go there because
right
right
who by the way you pretended was your
assistant for a long time right because
you were too embarrassed to admit you
were [ __ ] a girl that literally
graduated from high school yesterday
did i know that he was pretending yeah
yeah but he gave her his assistant for
like six months
i [ __ ] up
probably closer to my dad's age than
your girlfriend
would be more it would be more
appropriate for you to be in a
relationship with my dad than your
girlfriend that might actually be true
by the way i just want to clarify
you know nothing wrong with first of all
orphans not their fault
every kid deserves loving parents it's
just a horrible tragic thing so i don't
you know i have a lot of respect for
people that grow up in the system it's
hard it's a messed up crazy hard life
and you know for that experience i
actually do have sympathy for keemstar
and anyone that grows up in those
conditions and you know
it's a horrible situation
so just trying to make
you're trying to make the point that if
you're comparing that yeah i got you
okay
just saying just saying
my dad can beat up your dad considering
well my dad's good at shadow boxing is
my point
oh my god
i didn't get it
can't lie that was a good joke good one
ethan
dude
people are typing dear susan
let's not start this year with a bear
there we go there it is yeah let's start
it off
good i can get back to my h3 tv
today
i went after ethan's dad gary
i
ethan's dad is a bad dad he watches porn
and leaves comments on twitter
nothing like me
then he said
that i was left on a porch in a bread
basket at the fire station
actually that's just a lie that's
defamation i was left at a church
[Music]
anyway
i hit a dog this christmas it's been a
rough year
[Laughter]
true story true
it's too late in the day for this
we should wrap it up we got food waiting
for it so because it was good and got
good reviews from normal oh this is this
is unrelated meanwhile
anis
aniston residence
wait this is this is whatever it's just
a picture oh and that yoga position is
called okay who cares
oh yeah they're trying to prove that my
dad's racist
tucker if the nfl owners are racist why
are 70 of their employees black
my dad said
if slave owners are racist then why are
all their employees black
which you know
makes sense right he's make again saying
it doesn't mean just because their
employees are black that they can't be
racist right he's pointing out the irony
obvious very obvious so they started
clipping just this right
yeah and then trying to show that my
dad's a racist
uh if slave owners are racist then why
are all the yeah which out of context is
just kind of weird doesn't make any
sense he also follows this account that
mainly posts 18 year old girls dude it's
porn stars what do you want
you're actually [ __ ] an 18 year old
with braces who literally had to get a
permission slip from her mom to go on a
field trip to your house we don't know
that it's 18 but okay
hi ethan klein's dad and he's tagging
him like what the [ __ ] who harasses
someone's boomer parent he's literally
tagging my dad and harassing him on
twitter
well like if he said he's got it
he doesn't like it's like
this whole thing with women way more
pathetic knowing that you have already
addressed it on the show you've talked
many times so it's like what do you want
people know about my problems with my
dad yeah um hi ethan klein's dad this
girl messaged him because my dad we
because of the extensive conversations
we had on the podcast she said hi i'm
your biggest fan oh maybe i should
scroll down
i don't think i'm seeing it this is i am
your biggest fan
this is thank you for supporting women
who choose sex work and not putting us
down but empowering us all by watching
you on your podcasting cameo turn take
it off the screen for a sec
okay
i think he left a comment here here's
the damning evidence you're welcome
oh no actually the biggest crime is that
he misspelled your
no no actually not
you are welcome
um murderer
murderer yeah so you got him guys
got him
you're welcome
crazy
kavos another keemstar lackey you think
klein's dad bloody loves it let's see
that was a name i haven't heard in a
long time cabos what happened to that
guy this she still make content
i i don't know i literally haven't heard
that name in like two years you can see
her nude doing lesbian stuff if you
search well
viper i mean
wait where's the one he's okay so oh we
already saw this one but
what is this in reference to
my dad said i think your boobs are
crooked i mean dude what are you doing
such a dumb ass
why did he why would you say that that's
just that's kind of mean i mean i don't
have the context well yeah you don't
have maybe the picture was like
oh yeah i just don't give him the
benefit it doesn't matter sense that my
dad would leave me
no yeah
um so i'm gonna give him the benefit of
the doubt because i don't think he would
just be like nice boo nice crooked boobs
lady
you can see her this one's pretty funny
you can see you're nude and doing
lesbian stuff
if you search well
wait that was your dad
yeah that's my dad of course i was
giving giving advice yeah search well my
friend
dad
what the hell
it's just so funny to me like this group
of like 20 year old guys is just all
teaming up on this old man
and tagging him
yeah like antagonizing him
i'm sorry you guys
okay that's it so i mean you know
luckily my dad was pretty unbothered by
it but
you know they tried they were trying to
really
mm-hmm i think a lot of people are
imagining the overwhelmed [ __ ] about
this attention does he was he would he
even have been aware of it if you hadn't
like asked him about it
no he was aware of it he was responding
to them and [ __ ]
he told us about it it was like kim
starts trying to come after me
he was respond he was trying to be like
because they were trying to paint him as
a racist which isn't cool and he was
like look at the contacts he was just
leaving comments and stuff but it didn't
really take off in the
drama sphere just because it was so
obviously but keemstar made like a drama
alert about my dad too
didn't he maybe
it's not you get clickbait gary klein
sorry
probably why we went back to just
talking [ __ ] about pokeman all the time
i don't hate women
i think they had like a schedule while
we were on break let's start with the
old men then we'll move on to the women
go cover all the bases yeah
well i'm back
daddy's back the one you never had
oh god enough
[Applause]
just saying just saying i'm saying i'm
just saying it's keemstar's fault
hit me with it just saying zack
kavos's channel is like dead
50k views on a video from 10 days ago
so i'm saying like you fell off plus
ratio just saying
well now you just gave him content for
another video that's okay nobody's
watching
well they might if he clicks away at us
yeah the only video he has
recently that has views is one with uh
jake paul in the thumbnail okay
l ratio fell off
in real time on a youtube channel
uh don't i don't condone that
i have no part of that
okay so anyway again keemstar who
attacked my dad for being thirsty on
maine here's keemstar being horny on
maine and you tell me which one's worse
keemstar are you at least 18 i'll give
you another chance
nice boobs show me them on skype now
how are you going to compare that to
i will give you dick stop it
i'll beat it up big titties
you want would you want me to read one
of these again uh damn i mean just all
of them like
i will give you back stop it
you better stop it our next bks will be
in your butthole
stop i'm drunk and
you're using me for my greek god sperm
shared dna i'm down three-way
i'm not yours to share quit being greedy
ho
i'll lock you in seven rooms so get
ready for that labyrinth r word wow
want to be the random sexy [ __ ] on the
bks live stream tonight
okay now if you can just change your
underwear we would be getting somewhere
that's disgusting
shut up [ __ ] tit or get the [ __ ] out
i'm sorry
i'm bored bored type sex i'm bored
3 a.m skype sex
you're lucky my fave [ __ ] gave me her
blessings on your follow
16 more
take a dick to the face skank
let's make out c word can't even say
that can't say that keemstars okay
whatever shut up or your mouth will get
sperm what
who talks like don't shut up or your
mouth will get sperm for years
like
dude
tell him to learn how to trick shot then
suck his dick
you both suck that kick
keemstar
anyone from denver going to be there all
weekend fan meet up
at david
keemstar [ __ ]
please stop gawking on my profile pic
i'm a i'm a person not a piece of meat
i would honestly love for my first
wait
just carry a condom around easy to
conceal and great protection who does
drunk ops start what is all this
are we done tonight
uh if kim
i will be paying playing with your boobs
all night
toxins also using the n-word i mean so
like
just get off the horse there
sixth grade i'm gonna play with your
boobs all night so here's a girl she's
coming to his fan meetup
possibly 12 i mean who knows the age
wait let me go back up
here i mean that what's the age of that
girl he said boner
boner
breaking news confirmed
boner
literally just a boner
oh he's so he's so he's got such game
you know he's so suave
it's no wonder
alert it's no wonder the only people
that will touch him are ones who are
like literally
uh
let's say
i have no experience in life i don't
know who like don't know any better
show starts in 29 minutes retweet if
horny
you are too don't lie you coming on
i mean my [ __ ] i'm not easy ho
so this is how long ago
these are old but still
yeah like so we're gary so are my dad
nine years ago
or something like that well you gotta
remember he's like so he was exactly so
he was still 30 years old you know yeah
boner alert that's a third-year-old man
a boner
yeah so keemstar i mean shut the [ __ ] up
you're by the way
yeah
keemstar shut up yeah thank you [ __ ]
cap that off so that's about it
old-fashioned shut up [ __ ]
what is this baby
just a little reminder of all the stuff
he's tweeting about eli
mean past the horror stuff this is well
oh i can't play the audio
and they're so quick you can't because
he's just listening to uh hit him up by
tupac oh yeah this is what he posted at
the time it just says right after [ __ ]
you fat [ __ ] yeah i [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
yeah you sleep with 18 year olds dude
because you can't get a real woman so
and this is after right after ethy uh
leafy tweeted this is not a joke
keemstar just told me he slept with
ethan's
wife cool
and then he put out and he doesn't
understand why people think he hates
women or
um yeah like you didn't have a choice in
it or it's just like you're just this
idle [ __ ] doll
that uh
yeah
huh here is
the other side of the bed
leafy's a name i haven't heard in a
while either i wonder how his channel is
doing oh
oh and this
don't give him content he'll make a
video on instagram or something
facebook
what facebook
make a facebook video about you dan
he said in this card the
jeez
yeah and then there's the
hang on
the thread why is it not opening my
it's not opening my discord oh
oh this keyboard
monitor setup is just super fun
it won't open my discord
okay there it is
so then we got some other additional
stuff yeah this this thread is pretty
epic on its own he met he
responds to leafy and he's talking he
has three different video games all to
make fun of elo one's hit and run
one is called my horse and me and the
other one is super smash bros wait hold
on let me show it
this is not a joke keemstar just told me
he slept with ethan klein's wife i
couldn't show the original tweet since
leafy's banned on twitter as well all
right rip
that's pretty impressive to get banned
like
i think he may have a record i mean
that's something he could tell people
he's banned on every platform
it's funny how they parade around me
being like i'd like to see him survive
on platform today and i was right he got
banned off every platform at the time
and it didn't even take that long
and no one could do this like damages he
actually should have listened to me i
was trying to warn him yeah really
he blames you though it was good advice
he he thinks that you got him banned
that you they think a lot
i can't even get my videos monetized on
my new channel it's like i promise you
could work 24 7 and you can't do as much
damage as he does himself it's amazing
but like i've been literally tweeting at
team youtube
trying to get the new channel monetized
um and it's like i can't even [ __ ]
help myself bro how am i gonna get your
channel been
um
wait you sent me more stuff i wanted to
show it
you guys send me like an album cause
it's hard when
okay so this is good so
um he posting his games
hit and run i guess this was at the time
picked this up today my horse and me
that's of course
they were calling hilo a horse and kept
saying he slept with her another good
one super smash bros and again
this has nothing to do with ela he's
literally just
insulting her saying he [ __ ] her
calling her a horse because it doesn't
like me i mean what kind of purse
yeah obvious misogyny
oh yeah
the man hates women and i might hate my
mom too if she abandoned me when i was a
child so i mean i understand if he has
mommy issues and that's fine
briquettes
i'm covering my life
but i'm just saying he has a lot he's
clearly unloved that's what led to yes
who he is it went wrong
[Music]
yeah that's the other thing it's like
dude you think you could get a [ __ ]
real woman like ela i mean there's no
wonder you spend your your days outside
the high school seeing uh who's [ __ ]
impressed by your your mustang enough to
get in the car and spend a minute with
you
you know you have quad bikes looking for
the first girl who's like bill you have
quad bikes that's awesome what the hell
that's so cool
you want to see my man cave want to see
my you have a bar in your basement
that's freaking awesome can we go
um could you like
buy me some alcohol
do you have alcohol there
he just straight up said i [ __ ] her
yes
right
and then he kept being like oh what i
didn't say anything because it's all
like sort of not saying it directly
thinking that
it's fooling anyone
it's like just say what you're saying
yeah exactly he's a coward or maybe he
thought it was like defamation or
something so you didn't want to say it
no he's not it's the king slide it's
what he always does he always does that
yeah but he's like what i just said i
bought a game with a horse what um
um
he also made a drama alert about it
i remember oh he did yeah
in the dramaalert it's just all the
keemslide i remember him saying
something like i did not no matter what
the rumors say i would never you know
like he's trying to uh yeah well he's
just trying to make it a thing where
it's like now everyone he just wants
everyone to harass me and heal him being
like keep star [ __ ] your what i mean
he tried so hard with that horror stuff
it's uh
well
i picked up with a few people i still
get them here and well all the all
people that like nicola yeah
which again it's like if you're gonna
i'm not body shaming but if you're gonna
call someone a horse
at least show your face when you make
videos
i'm not wrong
did that guy do that too yeah of course
they they're all keemstar lackey horse
members gotcha i gotcha yeah i guess
that's how you become the air
heir to the crown
mm-hmm exactly just the ring although
didn't keem say like nobody can do what
i do and i'm not going to retire after
all or whatever yeah he's not oh poor
diorio
that's such an insult but the episodes
that diorio hosted got like really bad
viewership oh you don't say
wait so does he host them in person is
he showing himself no i think he's still
cartoon
i know
what i think he's been on keem's podcast
that a few times and then he did like a
documentary for keem but i think someone
else may have actually hosted it okay
yeah well i'm i'm not the uh well anyway
we got mexican food so that's that
um
you know what i'm saying
the the haters becoming too comfortable
out here in our absence
so we gotta let them know
we back there's a million more things to
talk about but on when you know what on
wednesday we were going to have oliver
tree but he he something came up right
dan
yeah so uh that's gonna have to be a
reschedule what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
dude
that sucks i was really looking forward
to that yeah we got a lot of fun stuff
planned for that episode i don't want to
give too much away but it's gonna be a
good one
okay well
maybe we can just keep catching up on
all this other stuff
yeah on one stage we didn't even get
through a quarter of the [ __ ] in this
dogs
all right guys well thank you if you
want more go to the h3tv
channel
it's gotta be some not like the h3tv
podcast it's gonna be so bad for search
results too
i like daily
maybe maybe not
i don't know who knows it's never been
done before no two channels same name
nobody's been that brave nobody's never
been done
i just h3 to my basement oh no
all right guys
all right all right we'll see you on
wednesday huh
come on thanks come
on welcome back everybody thanks for
being here
what a good time
what a blessed time to be alive
and thank you either for being here yeah
that was fun
but my my tags are so insane it's all
just like
straight up the verge of neo-nazi
reactionary conservatives
cool
wonderful spamming
straight up death threats too
it's weird that when you call
uh jordan peterson a gateway to the
alt-right yes that all these people show
up even though he's i know everybody's
telling you that he's not the gateway to
all right it's very strange where all
these where are all these nazis coming
from dude straight up nazis sending me
death threats like
really menacing
psychotic i love the the fun the most
ironic one to me is people saying
wow i thought we were free speech i'm
like [ __ ] it's my content okay you can
say whatever the [ __ ] you want no
[ __ ] free speech issue are you pro
can are you pro property right because
you deleted the episode they're saying
yeah yeah it's your speech
do i not own my property
i was thinking of that meme with the guy
where there's two buttons it's like
property ownership free speech yeah
oh that's epic
yeah that one got a lot like thousands
of likes
somebody said that's not fair dan they
could be rogan fans right that's true
this other guy whoever the [ __ ] this guy
there's an overlap yeah
this well we'll get into this on
wednesday i'm getting ahead of myself
but we have all the choice
response and everything we'll go over
but man these people are just wait
haley baker happy 25th birthday
oh do you want to read some stuff they
were crying about
wanting a shout out all episode uh
what's your name haley bailey baker
shout out 25 it's a big one wait do you
want to read it you're now officially
too old to date too old for keemstar
you must feel old now sorry wait do you
want to um
do you want to read some donations sure
give me one second load them up here
now we're gonna watch some hassan i love
you all peace and love have fun have fun
over there no go to hgtv [ __ ] this on
we're on no no no no no right now we're
on the podcast h3 tv not the channel
h3tv alpha beta donated 10 bucks and
said ila is so beautiful
thank you uh
peace and love uh
does that mean you're into horses
yo
what about you know what jack you got to
pull some of those sound bites of the
guy being like
what a beautiful mayor
look at her
oh
[Laughter]
uh
i'm looking i saw a lot of big ones so
i'm trying to make sure i hit those um
my roommate has coven has been hard on
me taking care of her alone thank you
for making me laugh guys peace and love
i am sorry marisol i hope your roommate
uh recovers and i hope you don't catch
catch some strays from
that rona
uh
we do eat burritos in mexico
says uh somebody who donated 50 uh pesos
so
they likely know what they're talking
about okay shout out to the
mexicans eating burritos in mexico we
love them mexican food is the best we
love our mexican our burrito eating
mexicans don't we folks somebody donate
250 pesos that said please you guys
should try mexican candy i may send you
some they're crazy i've had mexican
candy many times i hate it you don't
like it well they put like paprika on it
they like it and it's kind of like is
they coated in salty spice [ __ ] it's
spicy sweet a lot of it [ __ ] nasty
bro don't do it
come on i know they were i guess they
were just a lot
um well thank you everybody who is um
uh becoming a member who is donating it
means a lot i'm very happy to be back
we've all felt that void
[Applause]
and it's time to get back to work i had
nothing to listen to i listened to the
h3tv right that's nice
after the yeah
the podcast
you're in the room when he's recording
the other one yeah
yeah i want to give a quick shout out to
the crew and just thank you everyone for
being so
welcoming ethan mila thank you everyone
and the viewers have been so nice to me
ever since i came here too
shout out to everyone thank you guys
glad to have you here
all right guys we'll be back on
wednesday i'm gonna go eat a burrito
well love ya see you soon h3tv the
goddamn hdtv the channel now
[Music]
you